- Hey, Senator, and welcome.
Thank you.
I'm going to wait to start rambling until 6:30.
I don't know how the turnout's going to be because we usually don't talk about UFOX.
So if I do, it usually ends up either like a lot of people show up or no one shows up.
Depending on if they believe I'm going to be critical of what they're doing or saying, etc.
I do notice right now that there's only one other space with like a handful of people in it.
So it may also be that, no, Thursday at 6.30 is usually a solid time for spaces.
Who knows?
Maybe it's just because it's a nice day out.
We'll see.
Okay.
Hey, Bark Like a Duck.
Hey, Shane.
Wait until 6.30 to get going.
I was just telling Sinon that there doesn't seem to be very much going on with the X spaces today.
And I'm not sure if it's like the weather or...
Sometimes they wait until...
I don't know, 8.30 is astral space.
I don't think there's...
Well, Mav is at 7.
And the thing is, the evening is getting kind of full up.
But at the same time, we look at it right now, there's no one on.
So we'll see.
I have a nice ice cold, what we in Massachusetts refer to as a Nasty, which is a Narragansett,
which was a local beer when I was growing up.
And then it was so bad that it went away.
No one ever thought it would come back.
But then it became ironic to bring it back.
So they did.
That having been said, they make a decent summer shanty.
With, supposedly, Del's Lemonade, which is a...
I'm not from Rhode Island.
Narragansett is.
Del's Lemonade is.
Somehow, Del's Lemonade is not inexpensive.
So I doubt if it's actually in the Narragansett.
But who knows?
Maybe they have like a fake Del's Lemonade flavor or something made out of horse here.
Or, I don't know, cardboard or whatever they make those fake flavors out of.
Hey, Melissa.
I was just regaling everyone with the beer that I was drinking.
I'm drinking because we have like five minutes to go and I've got nothing to go until I get started.
So I'm like, yeah, I'm drinking Narragansett.
The key is to only have to run in good space if you're a drinker.
Not a problem drinker, right?
So you wind up with those guys, as you guys probably all know, who, you know, you've had some experiences with UFO acts, I'm sure.
Like there's a handful of guys who, their whole thing is getting hammered and then hosting spaces.
Which seems like, it seems counterintuitive.
I feel like if I was on a blackout or something, the last thing I'd want to do is record myself talking to, you know, 30 people.
Or like 30 people listening to me snore sometimes when, you know, sometimes when they pass out, that's what happens.
But they do.
There's a couple of guys who are like strong spaces drinkers.
But like, you know, half a beer or a beer, like just to get loosened up, that's, that's probably a positive.
Particularly with someone with a public speaking thing.
I wouldn't do anything else.
I know a lot of people who have spaces smoke weed.
I don't smoke weed.
Like I'm just old enough to have missed the universal weed smoking thing.
Like we did when I was a kid, that everyone kind of stopped.
And now, everyone smokes weed.
Yeah, so we've got about four minutes.
Hey, 2020, we're, we're going to be getting going in about four minutes.
I'm just kind of doing the pre-space spaces stuff.
Oh, I know what I can do.
I know what I can do while we're getting, who's there?
Ah, Tiffany.
All right, Tiffany.
Map Free Auto Insurance.
Fuck them.
That's what I can say before, before I get going on my regular space.
They have been torturing me for the last two months.
I had someone vandalize my car and they started torturing me.
Now, if we did, my insurance company.
And then I had someone drive into the same part of my car, like driving T-bone the side of my car.
And my insurance company is torturing me.
And then I had mentioned another space, like I almost feel like it's a sign.
Not a sign, not like, I don't believe in signs that tell you like you're, you're important, like more important than other people.
But I believe in like Jungian synchronicity.
Because the same spot in my car, like a raccoon darted out and ran headfirst into it.
As opposed to under my car, like two days after the accident.
And I'm like, what is, what is, you know, what is the universe trying to tell me here?
That's why I hobbled together my own personal meaning for it.
But I'm all wound up, so it ought to be interesting.
We'll see how long my public speaking can hold out.
Just about two minutes and I'll get going.
Just about two minutes and I'll get to the end of the day.
Hey Julian, just getting going in a minute.
I see from your photo, I think that that's where you're coming from.
You must have seen my little flyer.
I put those together because I never had a band when I was younger, basically.
And everyone used to put together those little flyers.
I never had a chance to, so I put them together for my spaces and that's really my hobby.
Talking in the spaces is just so that I can make flyers, to be honest with you.
This is about ufology, by the way.
I think you've got sort of...
Okay, good.
All right, so there are two words that have been coming up recently.
Not just in UFO X and UFO Spaces and on my Twitter feed, but I've noticed them coming
up like in conversations, on YouTube, in news articles, and they're one word we're familiar
with and one word, like we all know it personally, but it's not something that we've heard much
in the paranormal community over the years.
So the first word is interdimensional, right?
Oh, someone shut up.
Hey, Sadie.
So interdimensional is a word that comes up a lot.
And the problem with interdimensional is it doesn't mean anything.
I mean, it has a technical meaning, but it's never used in a technical sense.
So interdimensional has been coming up a lot talking about the phenomenon.
It's not, it's not aliens.
They're interdimensional.
So you're like, well, what the hell does that mean?
Right?
Like what?
Are they aliens from another dimension?
Hey, Mav, are they aliens from another dimension?
Are they?
I mean, what, you know, what do you think interdimensional means?
And the other one, the other word that has come up, and this is something that comes up a lot
with Mav, who is, by the way, he runs a space at seven o'clock.
I don't generally post his spaces.
And the only reason is, Mav, because I usually run spaces at seven o'clock on Thursdays and
Saturdays.
And you have, you get a lot of people and I don't want to erode my, you know, the few
people can really stand me on a week to week basis.
I don't want to erode that, but if you aren't listening to one of my spaces, then listening
to one of Mav's spaces is a great thing to do.
So the word that comes up a lot in Mav's space and it's coming up, you know, the first time
in the paranormal community, I heard somebody use the word Catholic more than a few times
and more than ironically.
Well, it was probably Diane Pasolka, right?
But other than Diane Pasolka, it's Mav.
So when Mav's show came around, it's sort of like a cross between coastal,
coast to coast, it's got like a strong coast to coast AM vibe.
I don't know what I was going to say it was crossed with, but, but also there's a strong
emphasis on his Catholic faith.
And like through the years, especially if you're an old coast to coast AM listener, they used
to have a guest, Malachi Martin, who was a Catholic priest.
And that was pretty much, if you were in the paranormal, you knew about Malachi Martin.
You may have known about the prophecies of St. Malachi.
Hey, Lou.
But other than that, you didn't really talk much about Catholicism.
It did show up.
Catholic imagery showed up in like the historical study of UFOs, right?
So if you read like Gods of Eden by William Bramley, which should be the first book someone
should have to read if they want to become, if they want to study the paranormal, if they
want to study ufology, you've got to read the Gods of Eden by William Bramley.
And in that book, and also in some Jacques Belay books, you know, they, they talk about religious
imagery seen in Catholic religious imagery seen in the UFO phenomenon, but you very rarely,
or at least in my experience, see someone coming into the UFO community and representing
a Catholic perspective.
And what was interesting about that is right after Mav, right after we discovered Mav's
show, like it was out there and plenty of people know.
It's not like we didn't discover it, like Europeans discovering an island with 10,000 people and
saying that the first person has ever been there.
Hey, Sal, like it's not that type of discovery.
I'm saying just in a personal sense, right?
We, we saw Mav's, uh, uh, show me and a couple of people I talk about online, talk to online
and talk about, and, uh, we started paying attention to his show and we're like, oh, this is really
interesting.
And, and then right after that, we started seeing the word Catholic pop everywhere.
David Grush just, um, the most recent example is David Grush coming out and mentioning his,
his Catholic faith where he hadn't really talked about his faith in the past.
And it was coming as a reaction to the recent, um, meeting of the, the, uh, pastors, the evangelical
pastors with, uh, some former members of the intelligence community, um, related to the upcoming UFO
disclosure, which is something that Mav had talked about in his space.
Uh, and you know, one of the questions that was asked was, you know, why were these evangelical
ministers, um, having a meeting with, um, former intelligence insiders when Catholic priests
and Orthodox priests were not included?
And of course the answer to that question is, cause that's not really the point of this
space.
So I can answer that question right off the bat and say the answer to that question is, it
is well documented that there is a strong connection between the intelligence community in the U S
and the evangelical community.
So that's, um, um, a criticism that is often leveled, uh, or in the past was leveled by journalists
from the left.
I'm not political, but that's where you would find that information and, uh, pretty well documented
over the years.
Uh, after nine 11, um, uh, the Bush, uh, a program for pastors that began like a program for
business leaders.
This was back when we were really afraid of terrorism and they sort of deputized all the
pastors and business leaders in the country into these programs.
So that the government could, um, network with them in order to like, see something, say something
and, um, you know, get the parishioners ready for changes.
If there were terrorist attacks, et cetera.
Um, and in fact, they actually armed, uh, they don't really remembers this, but they actually
went around and armed, um, top level management in some companies, like corporate guys.
Hey, Matt.
So they armed these, uh, these businesses.
I don't know if they armed the pastors or not.
They may have that.
It was a crazy time.
Right.
But since then there has been, uh, a connection and there are always accusations that evangelical
pastors are, um, an extension of the federal government at this time.
Now, you know, I, I'm not a federal government insider.
Um, I'm not any insider.
No.
Yeah.
Hey, go ahead, Matt.
So, um, my icon is a little off.
It has you listed as a speaker, but you should.
Oh, there you are.
Go ahead.
What's up, man?
No, I think you're right on the money and there's historical, uh, significance to it.
So, uh, as we expanded West, right.
When Christianity broke away from the church of England, you had evangelicals, right?
And it was part, it was very patriotic, right?
We were moving West.
We were conquering a new land.
Sure.
And there was no hierarchy.
They were Protestants, not evangelicals at that time.
But yeah.
Yeah.
So they're independent because there, there's no hierarchy and you had multiple pastors, uh,
different towns, you know, different, different theology, you know, um, or, or not theology,
but interpretation.
Right.
So it was very patriotic.
So it was kind of part of the whole U S Patriot system, right?
So the, as the Protestant movement moved West, you had the Catholics going from Spain coming
up, you know, through Mexico into California, uh, things like that.
So you got a strong Catholic presence on the West coast, but all through the Midwest.
That's why it's heavy Protestant, right?
Not a lot of Catholic.
Yes.
And, and I can see what you're saying.
It ties into the government because it's a very patriotic Christianity, um, loyal to
the country, no one else, but the country where Catholics take, you know, uh, are kind of shunned
upon because we take our, you know, we God first Pope first, right?
So the Pope says something, uh, we're going to go with what the Pope says versus the government
where, uh, the Protestant faith is basically, uh, uh, government based, like, uh, you know,
country first.
Right.
Um, so there is some historical data to why that.
Yeah.
Until recently, the U S was a predominantly Protestant country.
Now those demographics are changing, right?
But it wasn't like a 50, 50 split until very recently.
Um, so there was that factor as well, but there is, um, some sort of unofficial official
organizational connection.
And there's a, there's a name for the program.
Of course, I can't remember the name right now.
Um, but a lot of countries work through, right?
Like the, um, the former Soviet union and in Russia right now, right?
They work through the Orthodox church and in China, uh, Christian churches are often, um,
if not entirely, um, uh, working with the state.
Um, that's why they have, they have underground house churches there, right?
But they have official churches, but those, they're the, those, those people work for
the state, the priests and, um, pastors, et cetera.
Uh, in the West, the intelligence community has worked through Jehovah's witnesses, the
evangelical community, uh, Mormon church.
Of course we know that.
Uh, but you know, with the Mormons, it might be the other way around, right?
The Mormons working through the intelligence community, but it's the, um, the missionary
work being able to go places, learn the language, um, you know, observe a lot of people who
are involved in, in religious missionary work are under intense scrutiny when they're in
foreign countries that aren't a hundred percent friendly with the U S for that reason, because
they could be working as, you know, some sort of spies basically.
Um, and what, who is, and who isn't a spy sort of changes, right?
Depending on what the circumstances are, like, uh, you could, um, you could inadvertently
view, um, something involving an airplane in Russia, right?
And they could look at his, at that as some form of espionage, whereas you may not be directly
connected to the, but there are.
And with this gentleman, um, pastor, um, diddilio, diddilio, uh, he's awfully well polished, right?
He's awfully prepared for his moment in the spotlight.
Um, but you know, today really isn't about the pastor so much, uh, the pastor kind of, there
are times when the, so when we use the term SIOP, right?
SIOP is the military term for marketing, right?
Edward Bernays, the, um, the nephew of Sigmund Freud is the person who invented marketing and
he's the person who invented SIOPs.
So the term has been co-opted by the conspiracy community, psychological operations, but really
it's the military employing marketing.
And so the, the taboo nature of the term kind of stops people from talking about it a lot,
right?
Like even just talking about it in a space, I now are going to say, do I really want to
use the word SIOP?
Um, but there is a psychological operation, a marketing aspect heavily present in ufology.
And I think most of us know heavily present in UFO X.
I mean, that would be, I think many people's opinion, let's just put it that way.
Right now, the accusation always gets, you know, spread around.
Everyone's pointing at each other, calling each other a fed.
I think that most of us think it's probably overestimated, right?
And probably a lot of people are called, um, or accused of, of belonging, being some sort
of intelligence operative who aren't.
But I think we all know that there are those individuals here and they used to be here
officially, right?
Um, what's his name?
Doty, right?
Doty was a regular feature in spaces and he's one of the leaders in the government's counterintelligence
operation in the ufology space.
Right.
Um, Elizondo's guys, those people were all regulars in spaces at one point in time.
Um, uh, we have a tremendous number of individuals who are either like experts or they call themselves
whistleblowers when they're really not, who have a long career working with the intelligence
industry in different capacities.
Right.
So it's, it's no secret that this is going on.
It's just sort of poo-pooed and everyone's kind of gaslit if they talk about it, because
I don't know.
I mean, I think, I think that the main reason to be honest with you is people want to keep
the, um, kind of the glamour of, of the belief that this is like a grassroots community
and, you know, it's involving some sort of real activity.
No one really wants to think like, Hey, this is a controlled space.
Right.
But there's been a new addition to that controlled space.
Because it's, it's not just Mav now synchronicities happen, right?
Like everyone can just start talking about being Catholic without it meaning anything.
And you know, that very well could be the case here.
Right.
Like, I'm not saying that, you know, Mav is, uh, is wired into some sort of, you know, Catholic
thing going on in the ufology, um, community right now.
I will say that a number of individuals who strongly identify with their Catholic faith,
um, have appeared and begun running shows in the, um, in ufology and UFO space and have
appeared in UFO X at the same time, a number of public personalities connected to ufology
have, have emphasized their Catholic faith.
And it's sort of odd to have that happen at the same time.
I don't have from being from the Northeast, like I am, you know, um, most people up here
are Catholic or, or a large percentage of people up here are Catholic.
But even here, you know, there was a long period in the nineties and the aughts of like heavy
anti-Catholic propaganda.
And you had like a cafeteria Catholic situation where even most people who are Catholic weren't
really into it, at least in Massachusetts, maybe it was different in NYC.
Um, so like what, you know, let's just, we do a lot of thought exercises, right?
Like as a thought exercise though, like imagine if there was a reason that everyone was kind
like, uh, like there was a new, uh, uh, Catholic, um, not, I mean, the term I would use is faction,
right?
But let's, that's just coming from my oddball way of thinking, right?
Like a new Catholic perspective emerging on the paranormal and ufology or an older one.
I think, you know, I, Mav reminds everyone who listens to his spaces that the Catholic church
does have a position right on alien life and you can't limit the creativity of God.
You know, one thing that we run into in this country, particularly with the evangelical community
is the idea that the Bible says the earth is the only planet and the Bible doesn't say the earth
is the only planet, right?
So it's an interpretation.
They have an interpretation that the Bible says the earth is the only planet, but in reality,
we could be one amongst many.
Now it does say that Jesus is God's only son, the gotten son, but it definitely doesn't say,
um, this is the only planet.
And, and as people who, who've studied the Bible know it, you know, people will tell you
Adam and Eve are the first people, but they weren't right.
So maybe they were the first people who have descendants alive now, but you know, there
are other people mentioned in the old Testament, um, in, in Genesis.
So, um, I was having a discussion with someone, uh, about this recently, and we're throwing
around like hypothetical scenarios.
Like why, you know, why might the church be pivoting to addressing the, the extraterrestrial
situation, the paranormal, when, even though they've had, um, an official position, it's usually
been sort of a hands-off position, right?
And if, if we assume as a thought exercise, that there's an impetus coming someplace from
within the Catholic church itself.
And I actually think I know the answer to that question.
Um, a lot of people don't know this.
One of the, well, everyone knows about the Iran war and everyone knows that, you know, since
the Iran war started, no one has been talking about the Epstein files.
That's a very commonly remarked upon, um, situation.
I, a lot of people don't know about the Epstein files that the, the person or people responsible
for, um, getting ahold of those files.
That wasn't the U S government.
That was the Vatican, uh, under Pope Francis and, uh, Jeffrey Epstein and Steve Bannon,
believe it or not, I'm not political.
This is, I'm just relating this, the story.
Uh, this was in the Epstein files, um, were trying to hatch some sort of scheme to get
rid of Pope Francis.
And apparently this came to the attention of individuals in the Vatican.
And I guess it came to the attention of Pope Francis and the Catholic church were the one
who organized, hired finance, the hackers who, uh, who got ahold of all the Epstein files,
emails, the ones that were slowly being leaked to the public before the Iran war.
And so when we talk about like, there could be a shift in the Catholic perspective towards
ufology and paranormal, something must've changed or might've changed.
And what could that be?
Well, everything that was in the Epstein files that we know and everything that's in the Epstein
files that the government knows that we don't know, the Catholic church knows they know all
of it.
And, you know, for those of us who, I mean, I'm sure most of us don't want to talk about
it, right?
Like there are some pretty horrible things that were in those files.
I mean, look on the surface, the, the, the accusations, everyone knows are horrible, but
they're not nearly as horrible as the things that were actually in the files that people don't
like to talk about and you can say what you want about Catholicism.
There's been a lot of criticism, right?
Over the years.
Um, not to that extent.
Right.
So like whatever scandals they've, they've had, they haven't been accused of doing some
of the stuff that's in the, the Epstein files, right?
I mean, like some of the really, really, the stuff we don't want to talk about.
And, um, there's no reason to believe that, that they, that they, uh, would want anything
to do with it.
So Epstein was obsessed with UFOs.
He was obsessed with aliens.
He was obsessed with anti-gravity, with underground civilizations, with the location of Atlanta, everything that the average, no, no one in UFO X that I'm aware of has anything to do with that.
Jeffrey Epstein.
I'm not implying that or, nor that they're like him, but his interests, his focus, his passion,
his hobbies strongly would align, right?
Like the same type of things that fascinate people in the UFO X space certainly fascinated
Jeffrey Epstein.
And we have all those, or we, we had access to all those emails talking about it, uh, except
that he had billions and billions of dollars.
So he was trying to build anti-gravity shit, right?
Like he was trying to find Atlantis.
He wanted to move an off-world civilization.
He wanted to clone people, or depending on who you ask, he may have cloned people.
Um, he had, you know, some sort of crazy, uh, paranormal eugenics program going on.
He, uh, had regular conversations with people throughout the paranormal world.
Um, I don't have access to those emails anymore, so I'm not going to name names.
I only remember that he had a connection of some kind with Hal Puthoff and, and certainly
had a relationship with Deepak Chopra, Chopra.
Um, but I don't want to name any other names because I could, I might confabulate without
the, the text, the emails in hand, right?
So it is not beyond the realm of possibility to think that as part of the cleanup operation
or reaction to, um, the low-key conflict between the Vatican and Jeffrey Epstein and whomever
he represented.
Now, in the Epstein files itself, it seemed to indicate he was a fixer for one particular,
um, very well-known family.
I don't know anything about that and I no longer have any access to those files, so I'm not
going to elaborate on it, but it seemed that he, um, far from, rather than being a, an agent
for a number of intelligence agencies, which he's been accused of, may have been more of
a liaison to intelligence agencies from one very powerful, uh, family organization, right?
If, if, if you believe what he wrote in the emails in the Epstein files.
So, um, as part of that cleanup operation, like it would not be beyond the, as a thought
exercise, it would not be, um, beyond the realm of possibility for the, the church to have
decided to engage intellectually or, um, assert themselves intellectually in the paranormal
slash, um, ufology field, right?
I mean, it's the stereotype from all the propaganda in the nineties and the aughts was this idea
that like, historically there were these brilliant thinkers and they were just minding their own
business, thinking brilliant thoughts.
And along comes the inquisition, right?
And like blunders in there and says, oh, you can't think and sets them on fire.
Now I'm not saying that's what happened.
I'm saying like that was the, the stereotype, the caricature, the history channel version of
history.
That wasn't what happened.
Now the persecution did happen and it happened everywhere else too.
Right.
But, um, intellectually, the, the, the heavyweight intellectually in those conversations was generally
the Catholic church, which had been the center of education in a large part of the world for
several thousand years, right?
Like before there were universities, there were colleges and they were all run by, uh,
the Catholic church in, in Europe.
Right.
So, um, everything we have education wise now all came up and out of the community in the
Catholic church and in the East, the Orthodox church that, um, conserved that, that information
and educated people and you have to be very educated to be a priest, right?
You have to be extremely smart and educated to be an intellectual in the Catholic church.
And you always have had to.
So if there wasn't, uh, an impulse, an impetus, uh, uh, new direction, um, within the Catholic
community, um, related to the paranormal ufology, the, the reaction wouldn't be, at least in this
day and age, right?
Like there's no inquisition.
Um, the reaction would be to, to seed, um, communities involved in the paranormal, perhaps
hypothetically, potentially, uh, communities involved in the paranormal and ufology, um, with
educated individuals who could intellectually challenge what was happening in those communities
and also keep an eye out for, um, nefarious characters.
Um, and we know that one of the reasons claimed by individuals who formerly worked for intelligence
agencies, right?
Like everyone formerly worked for an intelligence agency and we've all heard that like, you know,
one is ever a former intelligence asset, but who knows?
We don't know that, right?
We're, we're not intelligence assets ourselves.
So we don't know if there's truth to that or not.
Um, but certainly all of the former intelligence assets that populate UFOX, uh, have, have told
us that, um, there is some sort of impulse organized movement to keep an eye on, um, on these
type of spaces for shady and nefarious individuals.
Now we've heard stories.
It's interesting in, in the last space I heard of Mavs, he had a different version of the same
story.
So he had a version involving a religious cult or sect inside a specific religion that
seemed to have an accelerationist point of view and, uh, seemed to believe highly in the
idea of, um, reptilian extraterrestrials coming back to planet earth and sort of taking over.
Now that, that, that sect, that story that, that he told is not one that we're familiar
with, but the story itself is one we're familiar with, right?
And the 25th of April, 2025 in Jolly, a former defense intelligence agent, um, gave a speech,
a space with red panda koala, where she outlined that she had been contacted by elements in
the intelligence community who told her there were accelerationist groups involved in, uh,
and, and, and, and, and, and, and ufology who believed that the reptilians related or talked
about by David Ike were coming back.
They were going to take over the planet and these individuals, these accelerationists were going to be, have a golden ticket.
I think fringe uses that term, right?
Have a golden ticket and we're going to live forever and help rule the earth.
So the, the, the cast of characters is different, but the story is the same.
So the story in Jolly told us was that individuals in the American intelligence community were looking out for those nefarious characters.
It would stand to reason that other communities would also be looking out for those same nefarious characters, right?
Regardless of whom we believe those nefarious characters are.
And I think that would vary depending on our perspective.
One thing that continues to come up in UFOX spaces.
Um, and I, I always have to remind everyone, I am not a member of UFOX, right?
I am a, uh, uh, uh, uh, in, in unwilling fellow traveler who just got grouped in because of the type of, um, things that we talk about me and my, my friends that the, the, the topics that we talk about just sort of got grouped in.
And with UFOX, because it's very close and, and extraterrestrials and interdimensional stuff is, is part of those topics.
Right.
So I guess like with the same topic told from a different perspective, but it doesn't mean that I'm part of whatever, whatever is, is UFOX.
Aside from being a community with like 4,000 members on X, although that was a long time ago, who knows?
It might have 40,000 or 400,000.
Now, I don't know.
Um, I haven't looked.
Uh, so same story.
Now, um, is it a coincidence that suddenly there's been this impulse in the paranormal community?
Is there, is it coincidental that we have, now, MAV, it's a coincidence with MAV, right?
It's a synchronicity.
But what about other people?
Well, I mean, are there other, um, professed Catholics very strong in their faith, uh, with a history of working for the intelligence community who are showing up to represent a certain person?
That's a synchronicity, uh, with a true perspective in ufology and in the online UFO spaces?
There, there certainly are.
So that's, that is a synchronicity.
That's all I'm saying.
That is a notable happenstance for that to happen all of a sudden when it's, it's never been the case before.
And one of the things that separates, you know, ufology from Catholicism is, is the association that ufology has had with Protestant groups, uh, evangelicals, Protestants, but also other types of Protestantism who evangelicals don't accept.
Like, we know Mormonism is often mentioned, right?
Um, Roshacrucianism, which is a Protestant movement, is mentioned.
Um, who are the, the weird guys?
Scientologists.
I mean, everyone's weird.
I'm, I'm weirder than anyone, so don't, please don't take it as a judgment.
Uh, Scientologists.
Although, I, you know, that's on the very edge of anything we can relate to Protestantism, right?
Um, but isn't it interesting that that's something that is sort of, you know, like Injali talked about in that, in that space on April, I believe April 25th, 2025, where she said the individuals in the intelligence agencies, right, are specifically looking at Mormons and Scientologists, right?
And we know that individuals sort of at the center of, um, or very prominent individuals in, uh, UFOX also have this fixation on Mormonism, a fixation on Scientology.
This comes up for us all the time, okay?
Because clairvoyance goes back thousands of years, right?
There are, clairvoyance is a natural byproduct of meditation for most people.
Predictable clairvoyance, but the majority of people who practice meditation in the long term have clairvoyant experiences, claircognizant experiences, clairaudient experiences, right?
ESP.
And this is a known issue all around the world in every religion, in every meditation community.
Now, so there's always been clairvoyance, but there were clairvoyant communities, right?
Active 2,000 years ago, like very serious clairvoyant communities active 2,000 years ago.
Um, and, you know, the original, speaking of Catholicism, right, the original split in the Christian community was between Christians who believed in clairvoyance and Christians who did not, right?
Orthodox Christians are the descendants, ideologically, of the Christians who did not believe in clairvoyance.
Um, the Christians that they split with, uh, would chant vowel sounds, would meditate by chanting long vowel sounds, ah, ee, o, I know it sounds weird, but that's what they did.
It's actually very similar to, like, Hindu mantras, and they would develop clairvoyant abilities.
Um, and, you know, you actually see that in, you know, not to separate on the subject, but you actually see that in ancient Christian documents.
If you look at the didache, D-I-D-A-C-H-E, right?
Um, the original Christian evangelists were not called the evangelists at that time.
They were called prophets, right?
So you, the head of your church weren't evangelists.
When the New Testament says, like, um, you know, the apostles and the evangelists, at that time, they called them the prophets, right?
And the reason for that was that they were actively prophesizing and actively, uh, engaged in what we would term to be claircognizant behavior today, right?
Clairvoyant behavior today.
Now, the argument has always been, well, you know, they were men of God, so theirs was sent by God.
People aren't men of God.
Theirs is sent by satanic force or demons.
That's a different argument, um, because there are NHI, right?
And there are, um, for the lack of a better term, demonic NHI, certainly.
Uh, but that in of itself does not mean that clairvoyance is demonic, right?
That's a, a leap.
And, uh, it's an extra biblical leap as well for people who have that, uh, philosophy.
So, uh, following this by math, he's going to go do a show.
So, following this, right, this strange chain of synchronicities that have brought all these, um, these, these gentlemen, mostly, right, um, into our lives recently, and their strong Catholicism, and their, um, their ability to argue the points of the Vatican's perspective on ufology, when that's something that hasn't happened in the paranormal community in my lifetime.
Like, that's, that's very interesting.
So, I believe that if that is, if that were the case, as a thought exercise, it may be a reaction to the Epstein situation.
And the discovery that there are nefarious groups with an obsession related to ufology, Atlantis, anti-gravity, under the earth, like, all of those themes, like, there, there, there are, like, we could have argued it before, but it was in the, it was in the files.
Right, that they, and, and, and people like them, um, were strongly interested in, and financing that type of stuff, right?
Like, um, there are emails between Deepak Chopra and Epstein addressing, um, potentially, right, like Epstein supporting remote viewing in some way.
Now, that doesn't mean that there's a connection between Jeffrey and Epstein and remote viewing, right?
Um, that's the same type of mentality that leads people to say, um, many of the original remote viewers were Scientologists.
There was an organized, clairvoyant practice in Scientology, therefore, remote viewing is Scientology.
Right, that's, that's not good logic.
That's, that's just somebody with an axe to grind who was looking to stigmatize people they don't agree with.
So, um, and again, that, that net, right?
Like, we all point the finger, if we wanted to, we could all point the finger at Scientologists, but then the next thing they do is point the finger at Mormons.
Then the next thing they do is point the finger at Roshacrucians.
I assume after Roshacrucians, they'd go after Freemasons, right?
Um, the Freemasonry is deeply connected to Roshacrucianism.
And the wave would just sort of keep spreading.
The, the ironic thing about this is, historically, right, Catholicism may have been on that train.
But in, in the paranormal and ufological community in the U.S. today, right, that is so heavily connected with Evangelical Protestantism, that creates sort of an odd situation.
Because ultimately, a lot of those individuals might also stigmatize the Catholic community and the Orthodox community.
As we've seen, right, there's this huge reinsert, as you guys probably have seen it, a young people who convert to Christianity aren't getting involved in Evangelicalism anymore.
They're converting to Orthodoxy and fundamental Catholicism.
It is a trip, man.
It is a trip.
Because if you told someone in the 1990s, particularly someone from New England, in the 1990s, that was something that would ever happen, not in a million years would I have ever predicted that was possible.
And I don't think anyone I knew would have.
The stigma and the, the outflow from the Catholic Church in the U.S. related to the, the, the, the priest scandals, like, that was huge.
It was overwhelming.
Like, someone was awed if they still had a fundamental Catholic point of view.
It's not the case anymore.
Those are huge, growing communities.
And now they're approaching the, the paranormal.
So, we're in this situation where, right, in a sense, and that's the, the name of the space, right, the crusade within ufology.
It really should be the crusade coming into ufology, right?
Like, the crusade has shown up.
That doesn't mean, that's not a pejorative, right?
Like, I'm not pointing fingers and saying, well, that person is not here in good faith.
I'm not.
Like, I, I believe Mav is here in good faith.
I believe Gene Stickle is here in good faith.
Um, I believe that while I might not support all of their views, when someone like Andra starts talking about the Catholicism, I believe them.
Right?
Like, I, there are other things that I, I don't think we would agree with.
And I'm not a fundamental Catholic myself, but I take that seriously.
Like, I'm not saying that they're not engaging in good faith.
If anything, perhaps they were unable to express themselves for a long time.
And now they're able to.
And that's what's causing this sort of general outpouring of sentiment.
But the outpouring is building.
And what we saw recently, we saw this Protestant or group of Protestant pastors kind of taken off with things, right?
Like, so they, and this is what happened the other day.
And this is like the crux of this issue.
This is the big turning point.
Okay?
Because we've had these groups show up.
And we have these groups running spaces now.
And they're doing a damn good job.
Sunday Syndicate with Gene Stickle.
Great space.
Mav spaces.
Great spaces.
Super popular.
Eclipsing anything that's going on in the UFOX space.
And let's be honest.
You know, mostly drama.
Right?
Mostly drama in UFOX space at this time.
Okay?
So, these guys are talking about, they're getting guests on.
They're interviewing them.
They're talking about, you know, coast-to-coast AM type themes.
People are into it.
And, you know, they're doing a really good job.
At the same time, we had this, like, thing going on with the Protestant pastors, right?
And meeting with the intelligence community.
And the intelligence community telling them to prepare for disclosure.
Supposedly.
Now, it turns out, right, we had an individual, very polished individual.
Someone who almost seemed prepared to come into spaces.
And prepared to begin running, like, YouTube videos and interviews about this subject.
And a group of other pastors saying that, like, what they were told in that meeting was that interdimensional, demonic UFOs were going to stage a deception and claim they were aliens.
That was the story the day that they came out.
And then the next day, one of them, like, one of the main characters, apologized and said that he had, that they were sort of running away with the story.
That they were sort of confabulating or twisting it to fit their ideological perspective.
And that really what happened was, I think it was Burleson, Representative Burleson, who came out and said, no, I did speak.
But what I said was, the evangelical community has to go back to the substance of the Bible as opposed to these extra-biblical perspectives.
Because they are not prepared for the information the government is going to release about aliens and UFOs.
Everyone connected to alien disclosure, UFO disclosure in the government seems to be of the belief that they are physical, flesh and blood aliens.
There is a group, everyone here knows this, right?
But there might be one person who doesn't.
That's why I'm, like, going over this stuff we all know.
So there's this one group, the Collins elite, supposedly, inside the U.S. military.
A group that people have been talking about since the 90s, since the 70s.
Which has always held the perspective that ufology and UFOs were a demonic phenomenon, masquerading as aliens.
And that, you know what, I'm not against that perspective, to be honest.
I don't think it's the entire story.
And that's where I stop.
I say, like, I don't think we should co-opt this, everything people are saying and all the evidence, and try to fit it into one particular perspective and one particular narrative.
And that's what happened.
And that's not the story that the government is going to release.
Like, we are not preparing for a disclosure where they come out and say, this is a demonic phenomenon.
There are some people in the government who seem to be, right?
Like the vice president, for instance.
But people don't hold that opinion.
Or don't seem to hold that opinion, right?
Because there are these factions, right?
We've got the aliens don't exist faction.
The aliens are demons faction.
The aliens are like flesh and blood, and they're coming back to world faction, right?
And, of course, the love and lighters, aliens are really here to help us.
They don't, but they want to.
At some point, they want to come down and do all this good stuff for us.
Just wait.
And now we have crusade, right?
And the crusade is here to say that the Catholic position is that they are real, that you cannot limit the creativity of God, that, of course, there are other worlds.
And if they arrive, they're going to be greeted as flesh and blood, and the Catholic Church is going to attempt to baptize them.
Right?
So that's their perspective.
And that is the perspective that is sort of coming out of nowhere.
It's the dark horse perspective that is coming out of nowhere to challenge the aliens or demons storyline.
And I'm going to wrap it up.
I don't know if anyone wants to talk, but I'm going to wrap it up by saying when I started running these spaces, I took it for granted that this was a UFO-related community, and therefore people believed in aliens.
It never occurred to me that that might not be true.
And that was my ignorance.
It was a generational flaw, right?
Because when I was younger, if you believed in, you know, UFOs, you believed in aliens.
It was only a process of getting to know people and running the spaces and listening to what other people had to say that it was slowly dawned on me, right?
And then I was eventually told straight out by some of the individuals involved, but listening to people's statements that not only did people not think
Flesh and blood UFOs were the most likely answer to the question, right?
They didn't think it was even possible answer to the question.
They said, people told me, look, we think maybe they're genies, jinn, plasma entities, interdimensional, ultra-terrestrial, or, you know, Atlanteans.
They all might be true, right?
Except that, you know, whenever you follow those lines of thinking, you get back to the interdimensional, which is the other word, right?
Etholicism is the word that's popped up for the first time.
Interdimensional is the word that gets recycled every once in a while when people don't want to believe in aliens.
They say they're interdimensional.
So they're life forms from another dimension.
So they're still aliens, right?
But they're aliens from another dimension.
Well, what does that mean?
That's not what dimensions actually are, as you guys all know, right?
Like, the fifth dimension is around us.
We just can't perceive it.
But if a being was a...
If they were from...
If they were...
Shit.
The thing is, only a few people can actually even explain what a fifth dimensional life one would be like, right?
But it's not what we tend to talk about.
But I think that when people use the term dimensions, they're using the term dimensions like they're playing 1970s D&D.
And they're using it, like, for planes of reality.
They're saying, like, these are from an alternate reality or they're from another plane of existence, which was the old term, which is this idea that they're...
Hey.
Come on up.
Oh, Kimball.
This is an unexpected pleasure.
How you doing, dude?
Dude.
Not this.
I'll take that as he's doing good.
Sorry.
When it brings you up, the audio cuts out.
I didn't hear what you said, but I assumed you asked how I was.
I'm doing well.
How are you, man?
Good.
Yeah.
So far, so good.
It's another day, right?
God gave us another day.
Another day, but or maybe not.
Are we on the eve of actual something happening?
I don't know.
I'm not managing my expectations, but this is heating up.
Yeah.
I mean, so something's going to happen.
It's just the question that's dividing everyone now is what level of honesty is there going
to be, right?
And what type of manipulation is going to be involved?
Like there'll be some truth and there'll be a lot of lies and there'll be an attempt to
manipulate us regardless of what they tell us, right?
So we just kind of have to figure out, you know, when it happens, we're going to have to
all kind of come together or as individuals figure out like how much we believe and what
we think it means.
Because, you know, again, psyops are just a word for marketing, right?
So like they're trying to market something to us, trying to manipulate us in some way.
Which one is it going to be?
Yeah, that's a really good point.
You think they're real, right?
UFOs?
Yeah, well, I know it's a funny question, dude, but a lot of people don't, right?
They think it's like people see something in the sky, but aliens specifically.
Yeah, I'm definitely like lower on like aliens.
Like I don't, that's further down on my list than it used to be for sure.
I mean, they could be extraterrestrial, you know, but I think it's more likely something
else.
Interdimensional, ultra terrestrial, breakaway civilization, time traveler or something.
I'm not sure if you've seen Carl Nell's chart.
He has a pretty extensive chart of like all the potential sources for the UAP hypothesis.
I can put it in your nest if you want, but it's pretty good.
There's a lot more than just ET.
Sure.
Go ahead and put it in the nest.
I may have seen it in the past.
I don't really remember it, but you can put it in the nest and everyone can take a look
at it.
Absolutely.
So if they come out and say, you know, the answer to this question is they're extraterrestrials,
they're aliens, they're from another planet and they want something from us or to give
something to us.
At that point, do you think it's likely it's some sort of deception?
I, yes, basically.
Like, I don't know why the U.S. government would tell us something that could in any way
jeopardize national security, at least, let alone their own power and influence, right?
Because if they're telling us, they're also telling China and Russia.
And so they would have had to have, right, if there are like reverse engineering programs
going on, like if that's real, they have to have like really, you know, nailed that down.
And what's the word?
Like, God, my mind's running blank.
Basically, they had to have like successfully reverse engineered that tech to a point where
they can use it, right?
And so they know that like if they let the cat out of the bag, sure, Russia and China, you
know, now know that we know, but we feel confident enough in what we have got from that technology
that we're not concerned about talking about it.
Does that make sense?
No, it makes perfect sense.
I mean, one of the problems that I always have, right, thinking logically about the concept
of a fake alien invasion or a disclosure of simulated alien beings of some kind, right, is that
it always tends to hinge on the idea that not only do we have a secret space program, but we
in fact have monstrous, massive ships, thousands and thousands of people, right?
Maybe millions of people living in off-world colonies and there are these massive ships flying
around and at some point they're going to stage, because in order to stage it, we're not talking
about like one fake alien ship.
We're talking about that theory is that they're going to show up with a bunch of fake alien
ships and like fake an attack or something.
They're going to be these massive vessels, and so the question I always have is, if that
were true, if we have that technology, then what in the name of God would they be doing
taking an alien invasion?
Like, if they go to these other planets and they've got these giant spaceships and everything,
what would they need to do that for?
At that point, who even cares what people think, right?
Like American citizens.
Do you see what I'm saying?
I do, and this will sound redundant to some people listening, Mike down there especially,
but I really love, I don't know if you ever heard, Brian Johnson had a theory that he put
out, it was actually part of the UFO log competition that happened a couple years ago, but in a
nutshell, his theory was that right for seven, eight decades, the U.S.
government, their main, like, psyop was to stigmatize the whole UFO topic, right?
Brush it off, sweep it under the rug, pretend like it wasn't real while they were trying to
reverse engineer some of this tech.
And now the new psyop, right?
Which they're not going to make it too obvious, kind of got to, like, crossfade into this new
direction, is to slowly acknowledge the reality of UFOs, right?
Even to the point of putting out the five observables of, like, what these NHI craft are doing.
And the reason for doing that is so that when Russia or China or Iran, you know, any of our
adversaries see craft in the sky, it could be ours, but we want them to think that it's
aliens, right?
That's kind of the new psyop.
Yeah, definitely.
I have noted, I think this is something I did a couple, well, I talked about in a couple
of spaces, that it was right when the tension started to ratchet up between the U.S. and
the Russians and the U.S. and the Chinese, which really started in 2017 with the trade
war, that the Navy started to reveal all this information, right?
I mean, I think that's around the time we got Mr. Elizondo, but it's also the time when
the Navy started to reveal all this information about these craft, and they said, oh, it can't
possibly be ours, it's super advanced, and it seemed like saber-rattling to me.
It seemed like indirectly showing off our capabilities without admitting to them in such a way that
they could be mimicked by the adversary.
So I do think that that's, you know, that's quite possibly something that's going on.
It's something that a lot of Americans don't realize, though, but I think people do if they're
part of the remote viewing community.
So the remote viewing community was a reaction to a program in Russia, in the Soviet Union,
right? So they had a very extensive, very large, long-term program investigating the paranormal
and trying to develop psychic abilities and utilize them.
And so our program was a response to their program, and probably never as successful.
That might be why there's a private remote viewing industry, because it may have been our
attempt to catch up, right, by doing what we do well and let the private sector build what
the government was not succeeding in building.
But the Soviet Union was very advanced technologically.
What they weren't, they weren't good at mass producing anything.
There's a tremendous corruption issue in the Russian culture.
And they've never been very good at actually delivering, building things and delivering them
when they're not being watched.
And I'm not saying that, I'm not saying that as like a slur against the Russian people.
I'm saying this is something observable that happened.
And it's still, at the beginning of the Ukraine war, it was a big issue because a lot of the
weapon systems, you know, had had parts sold off and stuff.
And they didn't know until they started the war.
They never do.
So it's always been a question around like Russian nuclear weapons for that reason.
Right.
But there were extensive leaks of information related to Russian technology in the Cold
War that, if it was true, was more advanced than our own.
And Russian politicians have always made those statements.
They've always claimed to have directed energy weapons that are more advanced than ours.
They've always claimed to have weapons platforms in orbit that are more advanced than ours.
This is not a secret they've claimed to cause earthquakes.
There was a public, an individual in the Duma made a public statement after Fukushima that
that that was a weapons test of a Russian weapon.
So it could also be that some of these things aren't us, right?
Like there's that whole like breakaway Germans, the Nazis did it.
But there could also be breakaway Soviets.
Hypothetically, there could be another...
Right.
There could be another country that is able to feel something like that.
I don't know if that's a fundamental thing.
Yeah, no, I mean, obviously, I think Russia especially, but China as well, have their own
programs if these are an actual thing, you know.
It presents a whole bunch of other questions like, would that make, you know,
SpaceX and all these other weapons, you know, the new B2s, the billions of dollars that we
spend on these things, is that all just like a false flag, right?
Because if we actually have this other tech, why are we spending so much money and resources
on, you know, rocket tech?
It's just, I don't know, poses some questions for sure.
Yeah, I mean, I think that Diane Pasolka advances the argument.
I think others have advanced that there's a ritualistic aspect to the rocket tech.
But, of course, who knows what the real story is there?
Depending on who you ask, right?
We're either on the moon and Mars and flying around Jupiter, or, you know, there's a dome and
we can't even get into space.
I mean, there are so many different perspectives, so many different stories and narratives.
It's hard to tell.
Now, while you're up here, in order to crank up a little drama, I really don't want to
crank up drama.
Hey, what's up, Logan?
That's my main man there.
Logan is the only person who's honest to me.
I do not want to crank up drama right now.
I want, like, if you choose to answer, I would like, like, an objective answer, if that's
possible, all right?
Something that I've noticed, and I do not have a problem with these individuals as people,
okay?
I find them entertaining, in fact.
I know that you do, and there's a bad history.
But something that I've noticed is that whenever someone new comes into, this is a rare pleasure,
okay, rare pleasure, Logan.
Whenever someone new is into the ufology spaces scene, UFOX, whatever, or UFOX adjacent,
if they're someone of importance or they're relevant to the new cycle, they're almost immediately
kind of cocooned.
And the same group of five or ten individuals kind of show up, set up a space with them,
end up co-hosting with them, end up selecting who gets to talk to them, sort of in the space
begins to spin the narrative, and then once that individual leaves, they kind of move on
to the next phase of what I would consider to be something propaganda-like, either debunking
what the person had to say or emphasizing what they had to say, depending on how they agree
with it, but spinning it for their own particular purposes.
And central to that, you know, again, two individuals I do not have a problem with.
I really can't stand some of the people who don't like them.
Not you, but, you know, there are some trolls, and I really don't like trolls.
But, you know, central to that is, of course, Red Panda and Tupac.
And what happened with that minister, the pastor, is he came in, and at the right moment, he kind
of said what people wanted to hear.
And it does not seem to be that that's actually what happened.
Like, according to Burleson, that's not what happened in the pastor's meeting.
According to other pastors who were there, at least one, Perry Stone, the most prominent,
that wasn't what was happening.
It was something they confabulated.
But that guy showed up in spaces, and, like, an hour later, right, an hour after the news
broke, or two hours after the news broke, he was in a space next to Red, with Red Panda
Koala as his co-host, cocooned, and having that narrative spun.
And then anything that's questioned that narrative since that time is a psy-op, right?
And the last thing that Red Panda Koala said to him was, be careful, because there are little
groups of agents, intelligence agents, in the spaces community, who might try to influence
you.
I don't know, man.
Doesn't it seem to you like that's standard operating procedure?
I mean, haven't you seen that in the past, personal feelings aside?
Isn't this something that sort of happens routinely?
Well, you know, I do think that...
Oh, I thought he was asking me.
Well, let me just kind of interject this for a second.
Go ahead.
I do think that...
People underestimate the level of friendship within the UFO community.
People have drama because we've all been in each other's lives for a long time.
People form core groups because they're also friends and have a lot of interactions off this
platform, you know, on other platforms.
So, I can see how, from the outside, that would look clicky.
But from, you know, what I've witnessed over the years, despite the drama, these people are
very close.
And there is a bond.
And I hope that people feel welcome when they come in.
But that may be, you know, you may be seeing something in a way that may not reflect the community.
Okay, that's a good point.
Oh, where did he go?
Did he bounce because I let you talk?
Kimball, dude, if you bounced because you felt like I was ignoring you, I wasn't.
I was talking to you.
But since Andra had started to speak, I thought the best thing to do would be just let her complete her thought.
It was not anything personal to you or no attempt on my part to disrespect you.
It just seemed like the easiest way to navigate that situation.
So, I hope that that didn't offend you.
And I appreciate the fact that you showed up and spoke in space.
I didn't expect it.
All right.
I'm sorry, Andra.
I just wanted to address that because I know sometimes, you know, he gets offended.
We all get offended, right?
He does.
Hopefully he'll be back.
No, we don't all get offended.
I mean, he, you know.
Andra's a white woman, you know.
And Kimball, he doesn't, you know.
No, so this really, I don't know if it's going to affect your spaces very much, Logan.
Your spaces tend to be, you know, there's a lot of dispute.
Now, you're not directly involved in the dispute.
You're more like a facilitator and an observer, right?
But there's, they've always, that I've seen, they tend to be, like, very dispute oriented.
And, you know, as time goes on, what Andra is referring to, the relationship, seem to involve more individuals sort of hindering each other moving forward or moving beyond whatever those long-term grievances are.
So it's kind of like a, it's an entertainment thing, right?
Like, and there's a tempo to it.
You can put them on in the background, and it's like having, it's like having the TV on.
Go ahead.
I'm sorry.
I wasn't trying to cut you off.
No, I'm sorry.
I was just agreeing with you.
That's all.
Uh, 2020.
Yeah, so that's, that's the whole thing.
That's, I, I like to just, most of the time, I don't even, it's on the background.
I don't even, um, I, I, I hear some stuff, and then I don't hear some stuff for a while, then I, then I hear more stuff.
Um.
Did I hear you say that?
I think I heard you say this, which is why I came up.
You said that I'm the only honest person around or something like that.
The only young person?
No.
No, honest person.
Is it honest?
Yeah, I mean, a couple times you told me to fuck off.
And as the only honest person, uh, everyone else is too polite.
Uh, honest in your relationship, relation to me, right?
Um.
Oh, we've met before?
No, we haven't met before, but you've, um, uh, we've had interactions online.
Yeah.
Small ones.
That's unfortunate that it went that way.
I imagine there was a good reason for it, though.
Yeah, of course there was.
It's not unfortunate.
It's not unfortunate, to be honest.
I'm from Massachusetts.
That's how we talk.
That's what I'm saying.
So I, I can, I can take that.
Right.
And, and it's genuine.
And I trust somebody more who's willing to express themselves in that way.
Right.
To me.
Because it's on it.
Yeah.
Careful.
2020.
What's up?
Go ahead, man.
I'm not hearing anything.
I don't know if you have any technological thing or what the deal is.
Does anyone else hear him?
No.
He was having this issue earlier today, too.
I'm not sure what it is.
Okay.
So before you got here, we were talking about the recent addition to Spaces community of a number of individuals who are strongly Catholic and represent that position and who have a history of working with the intelligence community and have come out of the intelligence community.
And they've now entered the ufology community to represent the Catholic perspective to people.
And what had come up in some back channels discussions was that this is not out of character at all.
This is generally, you know, despite the propaganda, this is generally how the church addresses these types of disputes is the challenge of intellectually, because in fact, you know, the Catholic church has been a center of learning and intellectual thought for a long time.
Um, and I was hypothetically as a thought exercise, right?
I said, like, we can't say for certain, um, obviously it's a synchronicity, obviously not intentional, but if it were intentional, if it was the result of some sort of impulse, like why might it be happening at this time?
Thought exercise.
And as a thought exercise, I pointed out that the Catholic church had been strongly involved with, I'll let you back up 2020 comment.
Um, the Catholic church, uh, was the organization that hacked the Epstein files and had access to all of those files before the U S government did, uh, before anyone else saw them.
How do we know that?
We do know that.
That's this public knowledge.
Oh, Francis.
So it was actually in the Epstein files as well.
So what happened was, uh, Steve Bannon and, um, Jeffrey Epstein were involved in some sort of effort to try to, or were thinking about ways to replace Pope Francis because he wasn't their guy, I guess.
Right.
It wasn't, he didn't represent what they thought would be ideal as the leadership of the Catholic church.
Who knows, um, Jeffrey Epstein was an incredibly powerful person, um, powerful in a way that we can't even, what his official role was, we'll never know, but it seemed to be a fixer for the people who were really in charge.
Um, but that's neither here nor there.
Right.
Uh, and as a reaction to that, somehow the church found out and, um, Pope Francis ordered his emails hacked.
And so they financed the effort.
They got their hackers.
I don't know if the Vatican has hackers and they hired hackers.
They hacked emails.
They turned them over to the U S.
So that's the story of the Epstein emails.
Now they had them prior to turning them over.
So the Catholic church, whatever was in those Epstein files, they saw them.
Right.
And probably saw all of them.
They probably have, you know, we could speculate.
I mean, they, they probably have the human resources or AI, you know, they probably have the technology to be able to condense that information, um, and to have access to, to it all.
Right.
Um, and the information in those files was horrific.
I mean, the things that we know that the common person knows about Epstein were horrific.
Right.
But there were nothing compared to what was in those files.
And, um, having access to that, uh, the thing that really stands out to me is his obsession with, uh, ufology.
His obsession with UFOs, uh, Atlantis, Atlanteans, underworld dwellers, anti-gravity research, um, eugenics, cloning, um, specifically eugenics involving, um, hybridizing human beings with animals, with extinct human beings like Neanderthals.
Like that was all in those, um, the idea that they were trying to create some sort of, uh, eugenic master race involving Swedish DNA.
That's, that's in the files.
That's, that's, that's, that's an established fact.
Um, Jelaine Maxwell was bringing Swedish men over to work for her for 90 days.
And she was collecting their hair from their pillows and their combs, uh, for genetic material, which, you know, if, if no one discovered it probably wasn't that creepy.
But if you were one of those guys, uh, and you discovered her taking the hair from your comb, that probably was pretty creepy.
But the shit they were up to, like those guys got off really easy, right?
If they just had their, their genes harvested.
2020, go ahead, man.
Uh, thanks, man.
Try it again.
Can you hear me now?
Yes.
Oh, or, oh, I let you up.
All right, dude.
Oh, that's cool.
You can, yeah, go ahead.
Yeah.
I can hear you now.
No, no problem.
I started this as a witness and I, you know, I still haven't really come forward with what it was I witnessed, but, uh, I had a long career within the government in a lot of sneaky places.
Um, on some of these forums have been actually booted because they think I'm some sort of Intel person.
I'm not.
Everyone thinks everyone's an Intel person here.
So.
Exactly.
I'm, I'm, I'm retired now.
And so I got a lot of time in my hands to, you know, creep around and, and X, but anyway, um, I've gone from, I think they're aliens that, you know, put fuel in the gas tank and fly here from somewhere to, uh, you know, I don't think it's that at all.
I think it's that at all.
I think it is more, if you want to call it aliens or I'm sorry, uh, angels and demons.
I'm, I'm, I'm kind of going with that now from some of the stuff I've seen and some of the people I've talked to.
Um, I'm going with the, um, I'm going with the, if you can't explain it as fucking magic, right?
I mean, it's, it's, it's that fucking simple.
If, if, if you can't point at something and go, yeah, I saw that thing come from here, from over there and they stop and put gas in it.
Well, if they're just fucking walking through walls and appearing and shit, that's magic.
And so that's beyond anything that any of us can relate to.
Okay.
Well, let me ask you a question then because of your experience and your knowledge.
So the Catholic churches, this is, you know, a lot to do with, um, Catholicism and the Catholic position, although I'm not a practicing Catholic, but that is the, there's the, uh, basic argument in the space, the basic discussion.
We also talk about the interdimensional thing in this space.
Okay.
So, um, the official Catholic position is you cannot limit the creativity of God that the Bible doesn't say this is the only planet, right?
It didn't say Jesus was the only son.
It doesn't say this is the only planet.
You can't limit the creativity of God.
And therefore it is, it is possible and likely that there are extraterrestrials.
It is possible and likely that that's what's going on with the phenomenon.
And should the extraterrestrials land and accept Jesus, they would baptize them.
So that that's been the official position of the Catholic church for a long time.
What, based on your experience, what do you think that's all about?
I think that the Catholic church in many churches are clinging onto an ideal that has been handed to them from generations.
And so you're talking Jesus, you know, approximately two, if you go, if you go through historical data and actually look at relevant texts that is considered relevant with history, Jesus was about 2000 years ago.
We'll say plus or minus, however much you want to say, and, you know, heard it through the grapevine.
I tell you a secret in 2000 years, what's that secret going to be to all the people that you've told?
Follow what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So it's, it's telephone.
Yeah, I get it.
So, so who knows exactly what happened 2000 years ago and even beyond that?
Or just one, one, we're going to get right to you.
So the pastors, right?
The pastors that came out the other day and said they had been briefed by intelligence officials and said that they were briefed that this is an alien and demon deception.
It turns out that Burleson, the guy who briefed them, said he never said that and said the exact opposite, in fact, that they had to stop holding extra biblical views on extraterrestrials and accept the possibility that they're real.
However, the pastors said, no, it's for, you know, we've been briefed.
There's a deception coming up that it's, it's angels and demons.
All right, so from your perspective, then, are evangelical pastors more in touch with the reality of the situation than the Catholic Church or the Orthodox Church?
Like, is there something about the American evangelical community that puts them into, gives them a better sense of what's really going on?
Let me give you an answer with the perspective of my background, okay?
As an employee of the government, as a special agent for years and years and years, I'm going to be able to tell you whatever it is I want you to buy, okay?
I mean, I've been trained thoroughly to get whatever my point is across to you.
And so, whoever it was in the intel community that gathered up a bunch of evangelical ministers or pastors that have a large following and a large audience, to me, that is nothing but pure diluting intelligence for a point.
And whether or not that's...
Do you believe there are evangelical pastors who work for the intelligence community in the United States of America?
Well, whether or not that intelligence that they gave to those pastors is true and accurate and 100%, I have no information to give you an answer on that.
But I am telling you, after working with the intelligence community for 30 fucking years, that whatever the boardroom decides, me as a little Indian is going to go out and make that happen.
Okay.
I don't know if we want to do the little Indian thing, but I hear what you're saying.
Now, speaking of aliens, we have a real alien here tonight.
That's Orr, and let's hear his perspective, if you don't mind.
Go ahead, Orr.
Well, why did I have you muted?
And what am I doing here?
What are my friends doing here?
What's going on?
Who are you people?
Well, it's diminutive thinking to say angels and demons and to belittle everybody, subjecting them to your delusions, etc.
There's a lot of stuff going on, lots of weird stuff going on, lots of upgrading in our thinking and the bandwidth for what we're saying.
What, what, what, who are you?
What, what are you talking about?
You talking to me or JT?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
So, uh, tonight we're talking about, tonight we're talking about the, um, reason.
Why did I have you muted?
Did you say some shit about me, bud?
Yeah, I think you're an asshole, but that's not-
Oh, that's all?
Okay, cool.
Well, we can get past that.
Oh, that's a given.
Yeah, absolutely.
So, no, uh, specifically tonight we're talking about the fact that while the evangelical community is coming out with the angels and demons narrative,
a number of, um, former intelligence agents, uh, with very strong fundamental Catholic views have emerged in the ufology community,
um, suddenly representing the Catholic perspective, which is sort of unusual in my lifetime in the paranormal community to have the Catholic perspective advocated in that way.
And so we were talking about, like, what, if anything, could it mean if we, if we stick with the thought exercise that it might mean something?
I'm going to help you with something, okay?
Actually, I got to find it for me.
It's in my, uh, son of a bitch.
One second.
Pilgrim.
Is it Pilgrim?
There it is.
I'm going to put it in your nest.
It's a scene from the 1977 hit film, Close Encounters of the Third Kind, right?
And at the end of the film, the main character, um, he, he, uh, there's a priest reading this prayer called the Pilgrim's Prayer.
And I actually found the actual prayer and the clips that they use in the movie.
Very specific verbiage.
Um, but, but this, this, um, conflation of religious tropes as an overlay for the, uh, the extraterrestrial, ultra-terrestrial problem, uh, is not new.
It has been around for a while, and it is, uh, an inevitable thing, right?
And you see it all throughout.
How do we deal with it?
It's in Man of Steel as well, where Kal-El, who is from Krypton, he, he is, uh, he, he consults.
The, uh, the, uh, don't interrupt you, Fade.
You'd like me to.
Can we let Orphan please know that it is?
Yes, I was, I was volunteering.
Son of a bitch.
I'm sorry.
We talked about this.
Yeah, don't step on my dick.
It's long.
Okay?
I understand.
It's not my problem.
Anyway, um, yeah, so, so this inoculation has been slow, and we're familiar that these things must come to bear.
They must come to terms with each other, um, and it is a gesture, and what's the nature of the gesture?
Well, we gotta preserve this thing.
We have to, um, we have to carefully handle this thing, this thing being the religious elephant in the room, right?
Because, um, there is a lot of confusion and misunderstanding about what it says in the beginning, which is, in the beginning, the heavens and the earth, all this stuff, Elohim is plural.
It is a plural term.
So, um, the ontology has been allowed to look a certain way for a long time, but now it must upgrade, and we've got to grow up and rip that band-aid off and say, hey, uh, we have collectively misunderstood a great many things, and, um, and that's okay.
And it will be interesting to see how these things eventually dovetail, because, well, we've had religion despite the, uh, the miscellany and, and, and miracle of life itself, you know?
And, um, it, it has been easily, uh, uh, easy to, um, disespouse, to destroy and dismantle, uh, the various notions that don't, uh, explain, uh, the world view.
But now the world view is about to pop for whatever reason.
That's the most, that's the most fascinating part of this whole thing, is the, the absolute imperative, right?
The mounting imperative, despite all the other things going on.
It's not a distraction.
I mean, it's distracting, right?
Yeah, we cannot deny the timing.
Uh, so that's, that's quite uncanny.
But, um, I also think it's going to be used as a reason to do a lot of stuff.
Which, um, it, it, it is alarming to me how many people are far too willing to adopt this, um, angels and demons overlay, which is very much coming from people who have no dog in the fight, who, who are not the ones to be making any kind of assessments or appraisals or, or, or reducing things to, uh, antique definitions and such, right?
Um, that part is definitely a PSYOP.
Okay, and make no mistake, it will be weaponized.
Bluebeam is not what you thought.
Did you expect that it would entail demonic possession?
Uh, no, I, as far as I know, Project Bluebeam comes from Star Trek.
Um, so, I'm, I'm still up in the air about whether it will actually be anything, right?
Because, uh, when Kimball was here, what I was saying is, is that, uh, you know, it sort of hinges on the idea that we've got, like, extraterrestrial colonies and giant starships and shit.
And, like, if I had a giant starship and an extraterrestrial colony, the last thing I would care about is, um, oppressing American rednecks.
You know, that's just me, right?
Like, I would go off into space.
I would go to the colony, whatever.
I wouldn't come back and stage a fake alien invasion in order to control, you know, to disarm, um, middle Americans.
So, I, I, I don't know.
I mean, I, if, if Bluebeam is real, then it's really pathetic.
That's, that's.
It is real.
It's happening right now.
They're, they're making new terrorists, new Russians, new, new, new, uh, uh, new asteroids, new, new threats, always contriving threats, always giving things a, um, a superfluous explanation that can be digested by, you know, the, uh, the mediocre masses.
All right, well, uh, thank you for the feedback.
Um, Fade, too, I know that you would have your hand up.
Uh, Tom the Baptist was here first.
If Tom would like to speak, then, um, I think we should let him talk first just because he was here.
Um, we haven't really been doing the hands-up thing, but I appreciate it.
Uh, Tom, would you like to say before I go to Fade?
No, I'm good.
Okay.
Fade, what's up?
Fade, too?
Okay.
You know, that's the thing about, it sucks, right?
You try to do the right thing, and every time you try to do the right thing, you always get screwed.
It's just how it works, man.
Who, me?
No, I don't know.
I'm not getting screwed.
It doesn't matter to me.
Right?
I mean, I don't, I didn't hear him saying, did he say something?
Did he say something inappropriate or something like that?
Nope.
Okay.
All right.
Uh, we'll try it again, Fade.
Uh, you might not be able to say anything.
Um, my spaces have a ton of technical problems, and that's probably more related to my-
I was just gonna say that I could, I was gonna play-
Yeah, go ahead.
Uh, Orr's, uh, what he was referring to, his, his, uh, what was it, Orr?
The, uh, Close Encounters?
We're gonna play a scene from Close Encounters?
Is it a brief scene?
Yes, it's brief.
All right.
Okay.
Mav, welcome back.
Oh, no problem.
I, I told everyone in my space, I said, we're gonna go jump out of here early.
We're gonna go raid JT and support him, because he always supports me.
I appreciate that.
Thank you.
And, um, I, I do support you.
You know that I've, as I, as I told you, uh, I don't know, Mav, Mav doesn't emphasize
this enough, in my opinion, but he's a, a former 9-11 first responder.
And for those of you who, uh, may be a little bit younger and not from New England, um, you
know, that's, in, in our world, that's about as, you know, as, as serious, um, the level
of respect you can have someone.
Um, so.
What makes him a former?
He was my friend before he was your friend.
You say he's a former?
Why is he a former?
Former 9-11 first responder, because 9-11 happened 25 years ago.
I mean, should he, should he still be responding to 9-11?
Mav, get out there, dude.
Well, I mean, I just mean, like, he, he was, I guess, yeah.
Oh, he is.
He's a 9-11.
Yeah, okay.
So that's, no, you, you know what, semantically, I'm, I, I leave a lot to be desired.
So, yeah, I'll say he is a 9-11.
Oh, 100%, 100,000%.
All right, Faye, do you have that, um, for Close Encounters thing?
Um, because otherwise we're gonna, we're gonna move on to something else.
Uh, it's not in the pill, I guess, or to drop him down, Lincoln.
Uh, wait, what?
I'm not gonna drop him down.
Drop four down.
He's, he's the one who's interrupting me.
I was just trying to offer as my service.
Thank you, Orr.
You're trying to play my video and it's in the nest, not in the pill.
Yeah.
Also, uh, I put that, the thing in the paper, or, I mean, the, the thing in the nest there,
the paper from the Vatican or whatever, talking about, like, their, um, their whole new theology
that they had kind of planned for last year or whatever it was to pass amongst their, uh,
their congregation or whatever they were gonna do, right?
Did you, did you see that last year?
Was that the, um, the statement that Snuggles read a couple of spaces ago?
Yeah.
The 2024 statement of discernment of supernatural, natural phenomena?
That was really interesting.
That is correct.
He, Snuggles, like, the leather and candlelight.
We gotta get the leather and candle thing back.
Like, he had this verbal tick for a while where he was talking about leather and, and candles.
I really appreciated that.
And then he moved forward and his new verbal ticks weren't like, I don't know, they didn't
do it as well for me.
So I, I, I, leather and candles.
I don't remember this.
It was like a leather and candlelight, uh, or maybe it was something else.
And in my, my terrible memory, it's this leather and candlelight.
Um, all right.
Uh, who's next map?
What do you got?
Or are you just hanging out?
Uh, I don't know.
I came in, I don't know.
Well, Matt, do you think that there are American intelligence, uh, assets in the evangelical pastor
community?
Uh, I think they're in every community.
Go ahead.
Sorry to cut you off.
I think they're in every community.
Do you think that there, would you, would you rate the, um, the level of, um, would you
say that, uh, there are as many in the, uh, Catholic, there's many Catholic priests who are
American intelligence assets as evangelical pastors, do you think hypothetically, if you had to
guess?
There could be, right?
Because they, they have some that serve in the military.
I, I mean, Catholic, I, uh, I think I've mentioned this a few times.
I think probably the largest intel agency in the world.
Think about it.
They're in every single country, multiple cities.
Uh, they all report back to the hierarchies, back to Rome and the institution has been around
for over 2000 years and what, uh, 2033.
They do have an intelligence service.
You know, then that's the, of the, of the space, right?
That crusade, uh, within the, it should really say the crusade arriving within ufology or,
or whatnot.
Because, um, you know, the Catholic church has always dealt with problems intellectually
first.
Um, you know, look, human beings are right.
Things have happened in the past, but they, they've never been afraid to stand toe to toe
with people intellectually.
And that, that's all, uh, just propaganda.
When people sort of claim that they would just show up and shoot first and ask questions
later, right?
And so pathetically, if there was an initiative in the Catholic church to address the, the
paranormal, to address ufology in a way they haven't done before, we would have people kind
of show up who were very educated individuals, perhaps people with a past in the intelligence
communities who are very, you know, um, strongly Catholic who might represent that aspect of
Catholicism, the intelligent, intelligence agency aspect of Catholicism.
The, you know, I mean, we would call them, I mean, ignorant people might call them Jesuits,
right?
Or Knights of Malta, et cetera.
But they're usually just like people who work for people.
Right.
Um, go ahead, Tom.
Well, the Knights of Malta had real CIA connections, right?
With, with, you know, documented.
Um, so that's not like a conspiracy theory that's documented history.
Well, they, they're uniforms.
That's why I, I, I chose a picture for the flyer for this space, right?
Like the Knights Templar get top billing, but the, the Knights Hospitaller, right?
Who became the Knights of Malta, like there, you, they look like Darth Vader, dude, with
that, the black and the black cross and the eight pointed star, like with the sword and
the spear, they're, they're the real deal.
And I think that if, if Hollywood had, had used them in more scenes, right, it would have
totally sort of transformed the image of what happened during the Crusades.
Go ahead.
You have to rattle, rattle off a few names, right?
Because Al Haig, I mean, there's been a ton of prominent Henry Kissinger, right?
With Sovereign Knights of Malta.
I mean, I wouldn't want to see him on a horse in a, you know, in a movie.
Go ahead, Faye.
Faye, too.
Okay.
All right.
I've got it queued up.
Here we go.
Times.
Think about how to cross and have your journey.
Show us your ways.
And lead us along your paths.
God has given you his angels charge over you.
Grant these pilgrims, we pray, a happy journey and peaceful days, so that with your holy angel
as a guide, they may safely reach their destination and find them.
And they may safely reach their destination in the world, and they may safely reach their destination.
And they may safely reach their destination.
And they may safely reach their destination, but they may safely reach their destination.
And they may safely reach their destination, and they may safely reach their destination.
And they may safely reach their destination, and they may safely reach their destination, and they may safely reach their destination.
So you want to cut it off, but it's very nice, but the horse's hooves are, I don't know if we necessarily need to hear that, but it was a very good clip.
That's a good clip.
Does anyone else want to talk, who's down there, want to come up and speak, say anything, have any specific insight into this situation, the emerging Catholic perspective in ufology, particularly the effect it may have on ufology?
Sorry, JT, I don't report the news. I just broadcast it. But, okay, thank you.
Yeah, I said bring it on. Bring on all the religious zealots. I mean, why not? And the intelligent people as well.
If I could ask, like, who is it that you are seeing or identifying as this emerging Catholic factor in ufology? I'm not sure I'm aware of what you mean.
Oh, I mean, Mav. Mav is, you know, vocally Catholic.
Oh, you mean you're on X. Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah. I mean, well, I mean, David Grush came out and talked about his Catholicism, and he hadn't in the past. He was reacting to something, right?
And the criticism around the pastors, I think that was leveled by a lot of people, was that it was evangelical pastors and not mainline pastors, not orthodox priests, not Catholic priests, but specifically evangelical pastors.
I think it jumped out, right?
And so that's where we were talking to Kimball, and I just want to throw this in there, right, before we go to everyone else.
One of the things that happens in UFOX spaces is there's a lot of dissipation, right?
And so sometimes if someone is talking about something, it's easy to kind of redirect.
And I was interested in Kimball's position, because I know that he doesn't get along with Tupac.
I know he doesn't get along with Red.
And I've noticed a certain pattern, and I wanted to know that if he had noticed that pattern as well.
Now, what I'm going to do is, because I feel badly that he's going to do, because Kimball and I don't get along.
And last time I checked, we had each other blocked.
I don't even know how he came up in the space.
I guess I unblocked him, or he unblocked me, or something.
Something happened, right?
So we had had some bad back-channel interactions, and I know there's a stigma, but that has nothing to do with me, right?
And I didn't like what went down there.
So next time, if Kimball ever comes back to my space, and he may never do so, right, I'm going to co-host him and let him mute people.
And I think that's the best solution so that there's no, like, interpersonal drama, and there's a little bit of a danger there.
I recognize that, but I think that's the best solution in the future.
What value do you place in Kimball, by the way?
Because you're kind of like a, going out like an extra for him, right?
But why?
No, no, I would do that for, I mean, anyone.
I would do that for anyone.
I think that, you know, it's important to be respectful of people who have different voices, and also people who are a little bit different.
Right, but he chose to be on his own, though.
As I've told you, right, like, I trust people more.
I have more respect for people who are willing to tell me off than people who aren't.
I'm from New England, and that's how we interact.
We don't hold back.
But that's not an example of that, because he just left on his own without even saying anything.
He did, but we'd had issues in the past, right?
And I think we know that's probably what happened.
Maybe it isn't.
If anyone here knows Kimball, I hope they'll relay my apologies to him.
And maybe not.
But if the same thing happened with you, I would feel the exact same way, right?
Maybe supper was ready.
Maybe.
Hey, look, I have criticisms, right?
So what we were talking about at that time was criticisms and observations I had of Red Panda Koala and Tupacabra.
I have nothing against them as individuals.
I don't really like Tupac as a person.
So I guess that's not true, but I don't have anything personal about him.
I just think he's bombastic, right?
He's actually very intelligent.
He's a lot more intelligent than he lets on.
And so I appreciate that about him.
But I also think it's tactical to sort of not emphasize how intelligent he is, right?
He's got that director's mind.
And, you know, he's also, his mind is very, like, you can, I can see why he's so successful using AI because he thinks like an AI to a certain degree.
And I think that's, he's got that whole, like, when South Park was trying to explain how Family Guy came up with this stuff with the manatees throwing the balls in the tube.
If you ever see that, it's a good South Park episode.
Like, he's like a cross between that and an AI.
You think he thinks like an AI?
He thinks, I think, in his mind, he's very, like, creative, you know?
Like, a lot of a storm throwing them all.
I think he is creative, but I think a lot of it is recombination, right?
Like, I think that that's the whole, that's why he's able to react so agilely, is that it's just second nature to him.
Like, he's got a very agile mind, and he's able to take a data set and mix it up and come up with something novel, basically.
But, so my, you know, what I was pointing out at that time was that when somebody new, if there's somebody who is in the news cycle,
or has a certain amount of status and they come on to X spaces, they will inevitably wind up in a cocoon surrounded by the same five or ten people.
Red panda, koala will inevitably end up being the co-host, and Tupa will be there.
And it will happen no matter what time of day the person comes into spaces, and I've seen it happen half a dozen times.
And so I was just asking somebody who doesn't have, who does have a critical perspective on them if they themselves had seen that happen.
So that was my specific question to him, because I've seen it happen.
I wasn't surprised at all.
Of course it happened.
Yeah.
I mean, and it could just be two adept influencers, right?
Two adept influencers trying to stay current and topical, but it could be something else as well.
I think people are going to be on top of it.
I can tell you what it is.
If you want to know, like, the real answer behind that.
Yeah, sure.
I got a little bit of inside knowledge there, right?
So Tupa.
Tupa and Red, right?
And maybe me for that matter, or whoever.
Like, we have been around, like, when spaces started popping up around, like, the UFO community, like, there wasn't really any, right?
Tupa was doing some, but then I started to do some, right?
And then we kind of just have been bonded, like, really ever since with Red as well, right?
And that's why we're always kind of just coasting, because we've just been around each other forever.
We're just kind of, like, close, you know?
That's why we do it.
That's not, like, some kind of, like, a tactic to, like, gain, like, some kind of advantage over whatever, right?
We're just close because we've been around for so long with around each other versus anyone else, you know?
It's just natural.
Let me ask a question.
What did, like, speaking of people who have, because I value people who have oppositional points of view, right?
So, for me and for others.
So, what would, say, Lou Elizondo or Richard Doty say is the motivation for that behavior from them?
What do you imagine their analysis might be?
For the behavior of friends hanging out with each other?
No, for the behavior of kind of seeking out people who are topical in the news cycle and cocooning them and sort of shepherding them through spaces.
And then afterwards, having, you know, sort of a set of responses ready, kind of propaganda-ish.
You know, Tupac was hitting that one pretty hard, right?
Red, a little bit.
But Tupac had.
I do know what you mean.
I do know what you mean by that, yeah.
And I think, like, a red does show, like, a lot of, like, red and Tupac kind of have that same beat with each other.
Like, they have the same kind of thinking about, like, a lot of things, right?
And I don't share a lot of that same thinking, which is, we disagree on a lot of things, but I don't know.
I mean, what do you think about that?
You think I'm, like, a simp for Red and Tupac?
A lot of people say that.
Are you asking me or do you say, Tom?
Tom, go ahead, Tom.
I would say no.
No?
I would say, you know, I think it's unfortunate, but there's that whole, you know, hate group thing.
And I think there's a lot of truth to that and then a lot of bad stuff on both sides.
It's just, like, an ugly mess.
And I just see that now.
That, to me, is almost like an icy activity.
It's just another hamster wheel to keep people from being focused on the issue.
And the issue is science.
And you have religion being dragged into the mix here because, you know, it's a big science issue.
So people are trying to get control of the science issue.
And this demons and aliens stuff is just a bunch of, you know, bullshit cover.
Now, I'm not saying there might not be aliens or there might not be demons, right?
But, you know, that's not the main show.
That's the main shit show you're being sold.
And I think the question is, you know, you've got to get a select committee or this community isn't serious.
And who paid these pastors?
That's what I want to know.
Do you think that it's standard operating procedure to possibly develop a few competing psychological operations and to play them off against each other in order to create an artificially controlled set of possibilities, a pseudo-choice, as they would call it in marketing?
That's textbook, right?
And I think maybe I'm wrong, but I kind of credit Logan with being pretty more open-minded than almost anything I've run into.
So he beats me, boots me pretty frequently, but I deserve it 90% of the time, probably.
So I think that's a good, you know, hand, but it's a pretty open mic, which is, and, you know, I think the issue is completely controlled in terms of what percentage of dialogue is out there is actual authentic dialogue versus controlled from one side or the other.
So the whole purpose is to control the narrative.
Yeah, or listen to Logan Spaces.
Yeah, I mean, I agree to a certain extent.
Yeah, definitely.
I don't have any criticisms, really.
I think the Spaces can be kind of Jerry Springer-ish, but that's why I'm listening to him.
So it's not a criticism to say that.
Highs and lows, right?
What up, JT, man?
How's it going, dude?
Go ahead.
I'll wax on somebody, I guess.
I think over the years I've grown to like Tupac, even though, you know, if you were here for the entire history, he has said a lot of things, and when he loses his shit, he loses his shit.
And it's important to bring back people into the fold, knowing, you know, the full context of his history and how, you know, if you know everything about him, you know that he's going to have an edge.
And that's what I like about him.
He's a narrative disruptor.
He is someone who he does say things, but he reels them back.
He doesn't follow me, and I understand.
I've pushed back really hard on him for some of the things that he said, and I don't think I deserve a follow for some of that.
But I still continue to join the spaces and try to add value and push back where I can so that the group doesn't feel like only the top five people are controlling the conversation because everybody can add value.
You just got to break through the mold, get up here, grab a mic, and add something to the conversation.
Is there just one Skywatcher, or are there a bunch of Skywatchers?
What exactly is going on with the Skywatcher thing?
I pick Skywalker because I like the Star Wars series.
And it's just an easy handle for me to...
Okay.
I had you confused with Skywatcher.
I'm definitely not a sun-tainting Esalon guy.
But as you were saying, though, just to point on the Lou Elizondo crew, it is proven by these guys here, a lot of these guys here, that only certain podcasters and certain influencers were getting ahead-of-the-line privileges or information as long as they were following a curated narrative.
And that is very evident as something that we don't want to see happen here.
So every voice, everybody contributes, and then we decide, each one of us personally, how this phenomenon or this topic is supposed to land and be digested.
Lou Elizondo is an anti-hero, but of heroic stature, if you know anything about his life.
And so I give him, you know, he served his country.
I guess he still is, in a sense, right?
Like, there's a very mixed there, right?
Like, I guess I come from a time when, like, around 9-11, when, you know, that was an important thing.
And even if he's got that sort of, like, you know, he was doing things that I wouldn't necessarily approve of, like, I'm still hesitant to say that he's, to just make a blanket judgment of him as being, you know, that his opposition would make.
Now, that having been said, he is surrounded by a bunch of world-class trolls, and that can't be accidental.
So I don't think that, you know, I don't think I'd be, I would ever be friends with Lou Elizondo, and I despise the type of behavior.
I mean, I cannot stand the type of behavior that I see from some of the people around him.
And anywhere, in a video game, on Facebook, on wherever it is, that's not my thing.
I'm just saying that it helps sometimes to think about, like, what would that person's perspective be?
That's all.
Faye Tu, that's all I got is Faye Tu.
What's up, man?
And then Andra.
Faye Tu, go ahead.
That Pilgrim's player was interesting.
Thanks, Orr, if you're still here.
Yeah, I don't know.
I guess.
I mean, it wasn't, you know, I wasn't offended by her or anything.
It was just kind of, I don't know.
Whatever.
Filled space.
All right, I'm not going to disrespect Orr.
I'm glad he came in here and, you know, and talked.
If I had realized it was Orr, I might not have let him up.
But, you know, I am a jackass, a jerk.
So my judgment of people isn't something that, you know, even I necessarily take seriously.
Guys, Ad Astra and Artisan, Andra had her hand up prior to you guys coming in.
So if she wants to say something, we should let her do that.
And then, yes, I might even drop down to listener.
But a bit of an update here.
This is a post by someone Astral reposted.
It's Pavel Abara Mega.
He says, Scoop, don't shoot the messenger.
But I'm hearing that between 600 and 700 documents will drop on Friday.
There is allegedly a very intriguing video from NASA that was recorded in the 60s.
And they described it as, quote, it wasn't the Chinese.
And, yes, this is the first batch.
The only detail here is that the files are expected to drop on Arrow.mil, not Aliens.gov, as it was reported.
But this is the start of a longer process.
I keep going back to what David Drush said this week, the next 60 to 90 days.
That's all.
The good thing about this is we're going to actually get to see UFOs again, right?
Like, in my day, people saw UFOs.
But that was before cell phone cameras.
So as soon as everyone got a cell phone camera in the hand, they stopped seeing UFOs.
They started seeing orbs, right?
But the orbs thing gets a little bit old because I'm just not excited by orbs.
It's just not my thing, right?
So you could get 150 people to come on here and talk about orbs and the things orbs said to them and, you know, the faces they saw on orbs.
And it would put me to sleep.
But you get a good UFO, that's it, right?
If it looks like it's made of metal or ceramic and it's zipped through space, maybe it blasts something.
I 100% has my attention.
So thank you for that update.
Artisan, I think you were here before Ad Astra.
You want to take it from here?
Yeah, I just wanted to make a comment about this whole thing where people assume that any organization has secret or special knowledge like, you know, the Vatican or the government or...
You know what I mean?
I think the only...
As a Christian, you know, practically my whole life, there's no...
The only knowledge that you have on earth is the discernment that you can earn while you're living, right?
There's no...
In other words, the idea that any group or individual has secret knowledge or special knowledge is just irrelevant, right?
All we have is what's in front of us.
We don't have angels or demons in front of us.
We don't have UFOs in front of us.
We don't have anything in front of us.
All we have is rhetoric and, you know, propaganda, misinformation, you know, and we have people, you know, it's funny.
When I interviewed Rick Doty, he confirmed that there were, you know, still these working groups on social media.
So in my mind, I have this, I imagine these working, you know, some little group approaching these pastors and promising them secret knowledge just to come.
And those pastors should have never agreed to a secret meeting, you know, especially religious leaders should never do that.
So anyway, it's kind of, as a Christian, it's kind of annoying to see the whole angels and demons thing because it just has this...
As a Christian, you have a certain discernment for these kind of things and you can smell the BS, you know, you can just smell, you can just feel it and smell it.
I hear what you're saying.
And, you know, it's a very, I assume you're American.
That's the sound of your voice.
It's a very Southern American perspective.
You know, the thing about the Catholic churches, they, we stopped paying attention to a lot of historical property law.
It was like a set of property law going all the way, all the way back.
You go all the way back to Hammurabi, right?
And what happened is when we like, when we started to industrialize and when liberty started to spread around the world, the United States had a big role in that, right?
Like, we just stopped sort of paying attention to what those things said.
Like, for instance, we ignore the fact that, you know, the king of England technically owns Australia and Canada, right?
Like, we ignore that.
We just don't take it seriously anymore.
It's never been, like, it never went to court that I'm aware of and was proven to be, to not be legal anymore.
It just, we stopped paying attention.
Now, the reason that's important is that, technically speaking, the Vatican, they own pretty much everything, man.
Like, they're a super powerful organization.
So when we're talking about the Vatican, there's really, the United States is the only comparable organization on earth as far as level of power.
That's your belief, that's your belief, you know?
What I'm talking about is historical legal, right?
So, like, if you can say, like, I don't believe the Vatican owns Brazil, right?
But it does.
They just don't, no one pays attention to those claims anymore.
But historically, it would have, right?
That's fine, but that has no bearing on me, you know what I mean?
Well, no, it doesn't have any bearing on you, but it does have a bearing on the type of information they have, right?
Because we're not talking about just an organization, right?
When I'm talking about just a church, we're talking about the first or second most powerful organization on earth, right?
Of anything, including countries.
So they would possibly have, right?
So I would think the U.S. would have special information.
I would think that probably the Russians do, maybe the Chinese, maybe the Japanese, and definitely the Vatican.
That's just where I'm coming from.
I mean, I'm sure they have information they consider special, you know?
But again, I've lived for 63 years now, and I haven't had any, you know, you know what I mean?
It hasn't had any bearing on my life, and it won't ever in my life.
So I think people should just live their lives and, you know, really try to work around this.
Well, you know, the thing about that is, is that this space is specifically about the Vatican, we could say infiltration, we could say elevation, we could use a different term of the advance of Catholic talking points and people who have a strong Catholic belief in the paranormal community and the ecology community.
So that's what we're talking about, right?
So, like, I hear what you're saying, but that's why we're going to keep talking about it, because that's the point of the space.
I thought you were looking for different viewpoints, that's all.
Well, we are looking for different viewpoints.
We are looking for different viewpoints, but when we hit the wall where it's like, well, I don't agree.
Okay, you don't agree.
I don't agree.
We've got to move on with the space is what I'm saying.
I'm not trying to be respectful, you know?
Ed Astro, what do you got?
Yeah, I was trying to figure out, so are you, when you're referring to, like, what you were talking about earlier with Tupa, kind of putting forward this narrative against Catholics, are you talking about sort of like that idea that, like, Catholics are sort of like a secret cabal, like devil worship?
Let me just be clear.
I never said Tupa is putting forward, hold on, I never said Tupa is putting forward anything against Catholics.
It's not what I, that's, like, very far from what I said.
What I said was that when Pastor Dadalio showed up in spaces, right, he was immediately sort of cocooned by a group of people, Tupa and Red being one of them, and they have a very strong voice.
And they tend to, even if it's, like, how they operate on a business level, they tend to act very similar to, like, what you would see from some form of propaganda, right?
So it's, propaganda is the government's method of marketing, right?
So it's the same thing, like, we don't say companies are engaging in propaganda, we say they're marketing, but it's the same thing.
So it's not a conspiratorial or paranoid accusation, it's just to say that they really seem to go out of their way to sort of take control of these narratives.
And, you know, the question is, well, why would that be?
Is it completely innocent? Possibly.
But we have to also admit the possibility that it's, there's something more to it, right?
So that's why I brought it up.
This isn't an anti-Tupa and Red space.
I have nothing against them.
I don't particularly like Tupa because I think it's a little bombastic, but it's not a personal thing.
That's just me.
And everyone, I run to people who dislike me all the time, probably 90 times as many people as dislike Tupa.
So it's not a judgment.
I find them entertaining.
I read their tweets.
I listen to their spaces.
I'm not criticizing them.
And I'm certainly not one of their adversaries.
I know they have many.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no, that's not what I meant.
I mean, I'm trying to answer your question.
So that's why they did that, is because they do follow the Christian national, like nationalist, like view of Catholics as being sort of like devil worshippers, sort of, or anti-Christian, and that it's sort of like a secret cabal.
And that's like the standard, like conspiratory, like view.
You know what?
That's a great answer.
The thing about that, though, is that neither one of them is Christian nationalists.
So that's what makes it.
Well, I'm just using that as a description.
No, no, you're right.
You're 100% correct.
But the reason that's interesting is because neither one of them is a Christian nationalist, to the best of our knowledge, right?
Yeah.
Hey, I don't know how much, I don't know if I'll be taking off in 20 minutes, in 30 minutes.
Kimball, I brought you up because, you know, I wanted to make sure that you felt that no one could talk over if you had something you wanted to say.
That's all.
So I gave you the co-host for that reason.
You can feel free.
Oh, is he gone?
Oh, connected.
Yeah, he took off.
Just to try and get you back on the conversation.
You were saying earlier, Baptists, that you should just be worried about what you can see and what you can't see and all this and that.
I agree, but this is important.
I respect your views, too.
But it's important to have you in here to explain your stance because there's a lot of people that believe what you believe.
And we're both in the same camp, like Christian Catholic here.
And I believe the Bible is an account of, you know, is a varied account of multidimensional contact and all of the above, right?
And it's written in a way to try to explain to us.
So everybody interprets it differently.
When I joined the military, I didn't realize how limited we are in sight and how dependent we are in infrared and all other bands.
So we can't see everything in front of us.
And that's the hardest thing to just accept is that not everything is available on human sight.
So keeping ourselves open and understanding there might be a there there is why we come into these spaces to discuss that we still live our lives and we still comprehend that we stay in the now.
And we probably have, you know, everyone interprets time differently.
But it does hold bearing in a lot of our lives.
And we want to make sure that we have, like, the most updated information, right?
Pushing back against every talking head in these spaces is important.
And like you said, talking about critically about why you don't get along with someone and explaining respectfully your stance, that I respect a lot.
So continue to get along and reach out to each other because you probably have more in common than not.
Thanks.
No, that's a good point.
But isn't that isn't that the irony of being human is that's what we do, right?
We seek out communities of people that we agree with.
We have things to say that interest us.
And then as soon as we as soon as we make that connection, we begin to identify or define everything by the differences that we have.
You know, you can see that like I remember when the Internet was new, like there were famous sites on Facebook involving like dog breeds who are famous for like having these incredible flame wars of people fighting over many school statements about, you know, rare dog breeds.
So it's just human nature and it's kind of ridiculous.
But I'm as susceptible to it as anyone, probably more so, to be completely honest.
All right.
Who's up next?
What do we got?
We got a lot of people drop down the listener.
Well, actually, on that point, you know, in terms of a dog war, I have to say, like, I got kind of pissed off.
And I just wanted to echo Tony's point when you see a bunch of these jokers come out and they want to use the pastor label and then they're selling clicks on the end of times.
Like, anytime somebody comes out to sell me the end of times, you know, they're not going to make that sale with me and I'm not so happy about it.
And if you're going to stick the government label on there, I mean, that's, I mean, beyond the pale.
Well, I mean, I think the issue of that is there's a strong connection or there has been historically, at least documented from the left.
I'm not political.
I'm definitely not on any side, politically speaking.
As a prognosticator, I can't really be because I wouldn't be objective.
That hasn't been said.
Like, the criticism has come from the left for a long time, detailing the extensive connections between certain members of the evangelical community and the intelligence community.
Now, ironically, like, this isn't a criticism because, like, right here, we've had members, former members of the intelligence community come into this space tonight, right?
Like, no one has a stronger connection to the intelligence community than the UFOX space and ufology in general.
So it's not like I'm saying, oh, those pastors, those terrible pastors are connected to intelligence.
I'm saying, you know, how connected are they and what relevance does that have to this specific story?
I think they're the most easily influenced, for sure, from an intelligence community standpoint, because the Vatican has been really hard-headed and not trying to, like, work with the Department of War on coming to theological solutions to any of the things that we're trying to fucking talk about.
So there hasn't been a lot of, you know, movement.
Maybe that's what they're trying to do is start with the pastors.
I think the pastors—
If it even happened.
I think the pastors and those in Congress are targets, not, you know, not intelligence assets.
They are targets of the intelligence assets.
So I just—it's sad, you know, but I don't think they themselves—I think they're promised special knowledge or, you know, then they're made to sign NDAs.
Why can't they tell us who they met with?
It's because they were probably made to sign an NDA, you know, preacher—pastor shouldn't be doing that kind of thing, working secret.
There's some mystery in Christianity.
So there's lots of red flags.
You're right.
100%.
I think that—well, here's the thing, though, right?
Like, they're not doing them any favors.
Like, sometimes people feel special or sometimes they're just manipulated or deceived, right?
But in the end, that relationship isn't doing them any favors.
That's a one-way relationship at best.
And it does compromise them to a certain degree.
So I would agree.
If I was a religious pastor, I don't have any association with the intelligence community, and they don't want anything from me because I've got nothing to offer them.
But if I was a Christian pastor, I wouldn't attend meetings like that.
I agree 100%.
Andra, what do you got?
Well, I just feel compelled to say this.
I think before we—because, you know, the way things amplify here—before we run with any narrative that these pastors were part of the intelligence community, you know, knowingly or unknowingly plotting for our, you know, not best interest.
I mean, I—why do I keep forgetting his name?
Alan DiDio.
I did take the time to go to his YouTube and watch his—well, his video is about an hour and a half, so I watched a third of it.
And it was kind of his response to his experience here on X in the last 48 hours and, you know, answering questions about the whole thing.
And in maybe the 15 minutes that I watched, I will say that I believe him to be a man of Christ, and I—or at the very least, I found aspects of what he was saying enriching, and I think we probably love the same God.
So it kind of makes me think that maybe before this entire community, like, burns these people to the ground, it might—it might just be worthy taking a little bit of time to find out what they're doing as pastors, what they say.
You know, maybe they're really caught up in something that they didn't plan for.
A hundred percent, right? And so to put it back into context, like, I would specifically say, like, from this specific perspective, right, I would say that you, Andra, definitely have connections to the intelligence agencies, right?
Not because you have it in your personal life, not because you've made a deal, but because you're in a community where you're interacting with people who are open about being—
I can not confirm that.
Right? So what I'm saying about them is the same thing that I would be saying if we were talking about somebody here who might be, you know, involved with the intelligence community, or someone here who said they were formerly involved in the intelligence community, but are no longer a member of the intelligence community.
So I'm not, like, setting him aside and saying he's not a man of God. I will say he's extremely polished, right?
And it does seem as if he was ready for this, but I don't—I can't judge him, and I am certainly not in a position to judge anyone's relationship with God.
I will tell you that. Like, I can be judgmental to people, but that one, I'm not—I wouldn't even—I wouldn't even go there because I am very far from a perfect person.
So, yeah, no, that's not here. Now, people do run away with these things, right? But that's why I ask questions. I don't try to make statements.
Right? Because I don't know. And so I'm just asking your opinion, their opinion. Who knows what people—what opinion people will run away with?
I don't know. But it's definitely not—they're not running away with my opinion. I'll say that.
Matt?
Well, I think, you know, it's almost pitchfork in hand. I think Tony's got the right line of questioning, which is, you can't have a meeting like this and come out and talk about it and fuck the end day or whatever that—you know, it's just—no.
That's just not the way—and I think that's why this community did a good job to say, you know, fuck that. That's bullshit, right?
Either you say who you met and, you know, let us work our way up the chain or, you know, don't put it on the table. Go away.
Yeah, I think that—I'm surprised that when Pastor Perry Stone, who is, I think, the most well-known member, came out and corrected and said, no, that was something that I added to what Representative Burleson and the intelligence community said to us.
I'm surprised that it seems Pastor Didlio doubled down rather than agreeing that there had been some misunderstanding, but he's going to be on Mav's show soon, right?
And when he is, he'll have a chance to explain that.
And, you know, we're not going to know until—right?
We're not going to—we're never going to know, but we're definitely not going to know what he has to say until we hear what he has to say.
Definitely.
Go ahead, Mav.
Yeah, I watched the whole YouTube video last night, and, man, he's very charismatic, very likable.
There were things that, like, he didn't really answer any question, like when someone—they were kind of looking through, like, the ex post.
And when someone would mention something, he'd be like, we covered that a month ago.
We're not going to get into detail.
But very likable man, very impressionable.
I kind of agreed with him, like if whatever these beings are come out saying they're the ones that created us, we were seeded, this and that.
If you're a Christian, you have to reject that.
You have to reject that.
So I agree with him on that theology.
But my theology as a Catholic verse, an end-time Pentecostal is different, right?
So I—maybe I'm a little biased just because on a theology point of view, but I know his followers are deeply devoted to everything that he says.
So he's a very powerful individual with the ones that listen to him.
Why do you think they appreciate him?
That's why he was a target.
Mav, did you expect him?
Yeah, it's end-time plus aliens.
That's like the textbook PSYOP, right?
Isn't that the word of Rembrandt?
Textbook PSYOP, right?
It could be a trouble book.
I just want to add one thing to what Mav said.
So there is room, Mav, at least from an evangelical standpoint, right?
There is room for the separation of God as the creator and a role that extraterrestrials, demons, or someone else may have played, right?
So there's a very familiar theme of human beings being manipulated after creation by God.
I would agree with you 100% that if someone comes out and says they created us, leave it at that, that's false, 100%.
But what I would say is that there's long been, at least in evangelical Protestant circles, the understanding that angels or fallen angels or watchers, Nephilim, Anunnaki, whatever you want to call them, did manipulate human beings genetically.
Now, I'm not saying you have to accept that.
I'm saying that that's a commonly held belief.
And it's also a commonly held belief in ancient cultures, right?
And if that were true, then it would be possible for them to make that statement.
It wouldn't be a complete statement, right?
Where they'd be saying, look, we created human beings who belong to us, but it would be more along the lines of we took what God created and we messed around with it, right?
So in that case, it would be perspective.
The problem with that is if you just look at the Bible as literature, that those things happened before the flood.
So, you know what I mean?
So there's no room really for after the flood for, you know, the Nephilim or whatever these manipulations are supposed to be of DNA.
You know, that's all considered, I guess, you know, kind of out there as far as Christians are concerned.
So what it was in the days of Noah, right?
So that's what they really latch on to.
People latch on to it.
But a lot of people, a lot of different interpretations latch on to the as it was in the days of Noah.
So it will be in that time.
So the idea is that if you believe that the flood happened because fallen angels were manipulating human beings and you believe the words of UFO experiencers who have had experiences where they believe that they're having children that are created to hybridize.
And the interpretation of that is that the same type of thing that was happening in the days of Noah is happening now.
So that's where that idea comes from.
That doesn't mean it's biblically sound, but I'm not the one to judge.
I just know why they say what they say.
And that's why I think that would be a good audience to target first, right?
Because they believe in end time prophecy and they believe it would be the same as in the days of Noah.
And they know that and they talk about that and they preach that.
My thing is, I have no agenda.
I'm open-minded in this.
I see, just from listening to experiencers and interviewing people here, there's a lot of parallels between alien abductions and demonic activity in the Catholic sense, right?
A lot of similarities, sleep paralysis, levitation, voices, visual things that aren't there.
Very similar.
I'm not saying it is what it is that, but that is a possibility.
So I leave that on the table.
The second part, there's things that just don't fit.
So I like to keep my mind open saying, well, could both be true at the same time?
Could we be dealing with something that's both?
And we're just not aware of it.
And even like with the Bible, you know, Genesis, you know, I always laugh about this.
They go, there were giants in those days.
And then it moves on.
Like, wait, what?
And in other days.
Yeah, can you go back and explain that a little bit?
One sentence, there were giants in those days.
And then it kind of just moves on.
Like, okay, back then, maybe it's like I have an Apple phone.
You don't have to really get in detail.
Maybe that's why it's not specific, because everyone knew what that meant.
Exactly, man.
Just like how Enoch is only seven words in the entire New Testament.
All we get is seven words.
And he survived.
Basically, Jesus took him back with him, it seems like.
So is he still around?
You know, it's confusing.
And everyone interprets it differently.
So it's good to talk about.
Mav, I think.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to come off.
So I think.
Oh, are you still.
I can't tell if you're talking because it's breaking up through the app.
I don't mean to be rude.
Go ahead.
So I think Gene is running his space, the Sunday Syndicate, which I recommend.
I don't know if he's going to be running it in just on YouTube or he's going to be running
it here in X again.
I recommend Mav's space.
I recommend Gene's as well.
I think the topic, if I'm not confused, is the aether, right?
And the reason that's pertinent to what you're saying is without launching into a long rant
about it, right, or a long explanation.
At one point in time, the world was divided into elements, right?
Like they didn't have 350 elements on the periodic table.
They had earth, water, fire, and air.
And there was a philosophical battle right before Christ, about 500 years before Christ, about
what element was the primary element that made up reality.
And some people said water, and some people said fire, and some people said air, right?
And some people said earth.
And materialism that we have, the world we have today, is the internalization of the metaphor
that earth is the primary element in the universe, right?
When you talk about spiritual, you say that is spiritual.
What you're talking about is the, if you especially go back into antiquity, you look at the actual
words that were used, they're talking about basically numus, right, of the air.
So that's the Greek.
So what it means is basically like as insubstantial as the air, right?
That's what spiritual means.
So when we talk to people who talk about djinn, right, they're talking about plasma-based life
forms, they're talking about, they're using the metaphor of fire as the primary element,
at least for the djinn, if not the primary element in the universe.
And I think there's a strong argument to me that Islam internalizes that metaphor of fire
as the primary element that the universe is composed out of, right?
Aether is the internalization of the primary element the universe is composed out of as water,
right?
So that's the difference.
Now, we have one that we settled on, and we use that one today.
But when you talk about something like the phenomenon, extraterrestrials, you know, when
people want to divide it and say they are either angels and demons and spiritual, or they
are plasma entities and djinn, or they are physical extraterrestrials, they're arguing internalized
metaphors.
They're not arguing the underlying reality behind the metaphor.
So you're correct.
It could very well be one, two, three, or four.
It could be all of the above, right?
Or none of the above.
Or none of the above, right.
But when you start using interdimensional, it doesn't mean anything, right?
It means something from a scientific point of view, but it doesn't mean anything in the
context they're using it, right?
So, I mean, that's...
Go ahead, Gary.
Well, if you're a Christian, you know, it's just irrelevant, really.
Okay.
UFOs and UFOs are just...
They're not a relevant subject if you're a Christian.
I mean, that's the Vatican's position.
Christianity is about the life of Christ, his birth, his life, his crucifixion, his teaching,
you know, his death, you know, and his, you know, promise of the future.
And then, you know, John 3, 16, that's what Christianity is about.
It's not about, you know, and this is...
These are distractions for Christians, and that's what's so annoying about dragging Christianity
into, or any religion, into ufology, is that it's almost like a hijacking or a need.
They need something to attach emotion, people's emotions, to the subject.
So let's drag Christianity into this, you know, it's just...
Anyway.
Yeah, you're right.
I think that the...
A good argument for it, though, if there is a good argument for it, right, is that there
is a belief that individuals who are behind in the intelligence community and the government,
a supernatural, not supernatural, supra-natural government, have an anti-Christian perspective,
and that this information is going to be released in such a way to weaken people's Christian faith.
And so, if you believe that's going to happen, and you believe this deception is coming,
and that it's specifically designed as an attack against Christians and Christian faith,
that's why...
That would be the rationalization for bringing people into the conversation who are Christian pastors and...
Christians are just going to ignore it.
This is what's so silly.
Nobody is going to have a fit about some fake UFO story.
I agree with that.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I agree.
There's not going to be an effect.
The story, the effect is what's happening now.
There's never going to be the thing that's coming.
It's always going to be coming.
It will never come.
It's always going to be in the future.
So, that's the whole gig.
Right.
I think you can say that about people in general.
Go ahead.
Okay.
I think you can say that about people in general.
Like, there's this whole meme, right?
This whole argument.
We can't tell you what the truth is, because if we tell you what the truth is, society is going to collapse.
And no one's going to give a shit.
All right?
There might be 10% of people who care.
And you might have to worry about anarchists who go out and do something crazy based on that.
But the vast majority of people are still going to go to work.
They're still going to buy food for their kids.
They're still going to, you know, do their hobbies, crossword puzzles.
They're still going to pray to the same God.
They're not going to care.
That's been a rationalization, a crutch for a long time in order to support all of the other psychological operations or marketing
or whatever they're doing based on this phenomenon.
We've got to go with Gary next, Matt.
But you can go after Gary.
Gary, go ahead.
Hey, what's up?
Can you hear me?
How are you doing?
I can hear you now.
Yeah.
Cool.
Basically, you brought interdimensional a little bit earlier.
As far as I'm aware, it's basically just a term to describe these entities that can like travel in between different dimensions.
So, I mean, they appear and disappear.
I don't really know.
But I just wanted to get y'all's perspective on that.
I mean, do you think it's just a word that they're just trying to put onto these things?
Because to me, it's trying to fit the scariest thing and the religion that supports it to kind of like be in line with the same topic.
Unfortunate, but yeah, Catholics are not going to fall for it.
We already kind of know what's up, man.
I think it's not really going to scare anybody.
Yeah.
It's 1970s D&D, right?
It's an internalization of like 1970s Dungeons & Dragons cosmology to explain the universe, right?
Like dimensions are height, width, depth, time, and whatever the other hypothetical three to six dimensions are, right?
That's what a dimension is.
You're not really interdimensional.
You could have something that has an added dimension, right?
Like above height, width, depth, and time.
I think they're using the term dimension with the connotation of like planes of reality, parallel realities that exist someplace else that aren't adjacent to us.
The problem with that, right, obviously is the universe.
The meaning of the word universe is everything that exists.
So something outside of the universe, you can't really say like outside the universe because that's really bad semantics.
So you have to pick a word and so you say interdimensional, but it really is just a filler word for someplace, something we can't perceive, right?
If they're from a place we can't perceive and we can't access and they come here and they do something, but that information, especially if it's ever disclosed, if they ever make that case, they are interdimensional, then somebody has got to do some work in describing exactly what that means, right?
Like we have to come up with at that point, if we have an interest in the subject, we get to come up with some like another term and another description for where exactly they are, right?
Saying like you can't even imagine it.
Well, that's problematic.
That's very problematic.
I mean, this isn't a space to talk about simulation theory, but at that point, then you're just in simulation theory territory at that point.
Tom, Mav, I think Tom was first.
And then Mav, Tom, go ahead.
Yeah, I just wanted to beat again the drum that says, you know, the community really needs to ask for a select community and to have the end of times community, right?
There's an incredible percentage of somewhere in the neighborhood of 25% of Americans or something crazy or American Christians think the end of times is now.
You know, I think that's kind of a number you don't want to be moving in an upward direction.
So that's where I find the government-sponsored, you know, aliens discussion with the end of times community to be, you know, on the face of it, some kind of illegal psyop.
Now, maybe I'm overreacting.
You know, it's where the crusade got my attention.
You know, if it is some kind of illegal psyop, you know, I'm ready to saddle up for the crusade.
But, you know, I guess keep the pistols in the holsters.
And just real quick on the dimensional point, you know, it's sad.
Americans are just stupid.
You know, I'm an American.
I love America.
But our education system sucks.
And people just don't understand a lot of the basics of science.
Like, we actually live in a four-dimensional, you know, space-time continuum at least, right?
So you can talk about, you know, frame-hopping, interdimensional, could be a whole range of different things, right?
Could be beings, could be consciousness, could be how you transit through the frames.
But I think an incredible high percentage of people, you know, only have, like, a three-dimensional, Newtonian, you know, Kantian, you know, kind of an understanding of the world that's basically 200 years old.
And I credit the Catholic Church for being, you know, the best way to try to push religion and science together.
You know, neither should ever conflict with the other.
And I think we are in a Galileo-like moment where this is all about science and all this demons, aliens, all the rest of it's just bullshit.
It's all about science and the science is low-energy nuclear reactions, and it's kept secret because that would destabilize the oil economy and all the Mansfield dimension and, you know, Invention Secrecy Act and all the Atomic Energy Commission, you know, all that stuff is written to preserve the strategic advantage of the United States, which is, you know, oil petroleum economy.
We're in the cat's bird seat on the planet of an oil petroleum economy.
So the low-energy nuclear reaction science is kept secret, and that's kind of proven in the Epstein files, right, because they took credit for killing Pons and Fleischmann.
So the PSYOP, I think to Tony's point, is that, like, the information is out there.
There's nothing you don't know.
The PSYOP is controlling the narrative on both sides, so there's no voice in the middle saying, holy shit, here's all the data that you could look at scientifically, and you don't have to have an emotional dogfight about.
So, and you might actually agree on what the hell is true, but we're kind of never given that opportunity, which is, this is kind of a, maybe a different space.
I don't really know you, JT, but I was just going to bust your chops.
You're probably a fed if you're JT McCarthy, right?
Any Joseph McCarthy background disclosure points you need to do, anything like that?
No, no, not at the moment.
I'm not really political, but, yeah, no.
Hey, Matt, go ahead, man.
Tony, I don't know why I had you blocked, you blocked me.
We seem to agree on a lot of things, so I unblocked you, so I don't even remember why you blocked each other.
That was the first thing I did when I came into space.
I was like, why is Matt blocked?
I don't know, it's kind of funny.
I don't remember why.
It was probably something stupid.
But as a Catholic, right, if aliens landed on the front lawn of the White House and got out, it wouldn't ruin my faith.
It would reinforce my faith.
And I did talk to a Catholic priest about it back when 3i Atlas was coming through.
I was like, you want to be in my space when I had Avi Loeb?
So I'm like, I want to know what the Catholic and the Christian point of view would be if this thing was, quote, unquote, alien, right?
And I talked to him on the phone for about an hour, and he's like, it's not anti-biblical that there could be a species from another planet.
Matter of fact, if you're against that as a Christian, then you're limiting what God's capable of doing.
I'm like, oh, that's interesting.
I never thought of it that way.
And he's like, there's nothing in there that says there's not other beings.
And then there's still the possibility of, like, the demon thing, right?
We do have, I believe there's possession.
I believe that stuff is true.
There could be a combination.
What scares me is when you get into, like, like, Alan seems like a really nice guy.
I would love to sit down, have dinner with him, and talk to him, even though our theologies are different.
But when you focus, it's like that red card theory.
When you focus on the end time and demonic activity all the time, you see it on everything.
That scares the crap out of me.
And then also, him and the other pastors that came out, I did a search.
They all run the same circle.
They're all on each other's podcast.
They're all on each other's YouTube channels.
They're all friends.
They belong to, I think it's called CRN, which helps them with their production, their social media.
I mean, brilliant.
You want to learn how to grow your account.
You want to learn how to do what, follow that site.
Oh, my Lord.
Their productions are outstanding.
That scares me, because if you don't follow that belief system, right, because I always wonder, I'm like, how would, in the end, like, now I'm talking about the end times.
How would it be that the Christians would be rounded up and executed, right?
And then I see what's going on with the war in the Middle East, right, and the Zionist, the Christian Zionist.
I see what's going on now with them pushing the demon agenda with the, you know, the Pentecostals.
And I'm like, I can see how this could happen.
So now if you have Christians and things that don't believe what they're telling us, right, and you have some figure come forth saying we have to fight these demonic things, and there's those of us who are Christians who don't believe what they're saying.
They could round us up and say we're part of their agenda, or we've been hijacked, or we're demonically possessed.
You see where it could go if you get people that, if you box yourself into a corner.
I think that's what they want people to think, but I don't think that will be true.
But I think that, I don't mean to be mean to those types of people, but the people who focus on the end times are the people that those people target, right?
Those are the people that are emotionally susceptible to this kind of thing.
If you're just an everyday Christian, there's no need for worry.
There's no need for fear.
There's no need for UFOs or aliens.
There's no need for any of that.
That's not what we focus on.
So I know people don't like to hear that in ufology, but it's just they need to get a new gig because 90% of the Christians aren't going to fall for these types of things,
and if they want to manipulate more people, they're going to have to get a better story.
That's the way I'm looking at it.
We're definitely going to see, right?
We're definitely going to see what happens.
Ironically, again, like the narrative, when you're engaged in the evangelical community,
the narrative is clearly there, that there's an omnipresent threat of persecution.
There are Christian communities around the world that are frequently persecuted.
They're very rarely part of the evangelical community.
They're very rarely connected to American evangelicals.
And likening the feelings of persecution that people in the U.S. who belong to a certain religious group have to the experience of persecution that, say, a Coptic Christian has,
or a Yazidi, if we go outside the church, right?
Like that's, that in itself is narcissistic.
That having been said, like we are seeing, like we're, from right now, from this vantage point,
if you look at what's happening, it seems as if, when you have like these meetings, right,
it seems as if the connection, the insider status is involving the evangelical community.
And there, particularly those of us in UFOX have heard repeatedly that there's a focus on other religious groups,
particularly the one that is hammered home every day on here, the ones, is Scientology, Mormonism, and, believe it or not, Rosicrucianism, right?
So those are the three, because apparently they're related to the ufology topic, right, that are always in the forefront of everyone's minds.
It also seems that, if we believe what people are saying, there is, there are at least some people involved in power
who have, who have, who want to limit the freedom of action of individuals involved in groups like that
related to their beliefs in aliens.
Now, that's not something that I'm saying, that's something that people like Injali have come into the community
and said that they were, they were told by connections they have in the intelligence community
that the, that they're looking into are like people who follow David Icke, accelerationists,
some really bad actor groups of people, and that have nothing to do with anyone,
but apparently are somewhat represented in ufology.
And then Mormonism, Scientology, and Rosicrucianism.
Because it seems that what they're saying is it's the belief in, in aliens.
I'm going to go on a limb.
This is like, this is a topic for a different space.
However, there is one taboo subject that you can find throughout UFOX and through a portion of ufology at this time.
And that is, it is a very taboo.
People feel a taboo talking about it.
And if you talk about reptilians.
Hi, JT.
Hey, how you doing?
Just one second, Cleo.
If you talk about reptilians, right?
Someone will send you, inevitably send you a message in the back channel saying like,
we don't believe in that.
We don't talk about that.
No one takes that seriously.
And the stories that we've heard about groups being targeted also seem to connect.
Part of the narrative is because they have a belief in the literal existence of reptilians.
I don't know what to say.
Because if someone had told me like, what's the one issue that's taboo in ufology?
Like, I would never have guessed that.
And it's something that I didn't really take seriously.
It makes me wonder that it's such a taboo.
That's all I'm going to say.
Go ahead, Cleo.
I'm sorry to cut you off.
Go ahead.
I just wanted to say hello, JT.
I really love that you're into metaphysics, astrology, non-violence gaming spaces, including
gothic and apologetic.
Yeah, I love all of that.
Cool.
Thank you.
I'm enjoying some fried rice.
I just wanted to know, JT, are you a Virgo?
What's going on?
No, I'm not a Virgo.
No.
But sometimes Capricorn.
Do you like long walks on the beach?
No, I just...
Yeah, and big dicks.
I got a question, though.
So I had a Ethiopian...
Not Ethiopian.
Hi, Skywalker.
What's up, buddy?
I had a Nigerian priest when I was stationed in D.C. at the Air Force Base.
Nobody ever showed up to church.
It was just a couple of families, and he would always scold us about how nobody was believing
at the time.
I always pushed back after church because he would go so hard on us about how the attendance
rate sucks at military churches and all this and that.
Nobody has time to go to church, but my thing was theologically was the way the DOD and
Lou Elizondo and company at the time while I was stationed in D.C. was going and having
meetings at the Vatican, right?
And so I was found that very suspicious and collected the data points and understood that
MKUltra documents were being released at the time, side subject.
But the theological implications are...
I lost my fucking frame of thought, dude.
What I was thinking is that basically...
I'll come back.
Go ahead and take over, man.
I forget what I was going to land with.
By the way, Lou Elizondo may have had many interactions with the Catholic Church.
I don't know anything about it.
I don't know too much about his ufological activities, real or...
I mean, I assume they're all real.
Who knows?
I can say that from what I understand, he's not Catholic.
So it would be from an outsider's perspective interacting with the Catholic Church, just purely
based on his job description.
Go ahead, Tom.
Yeah, I can just pick up a little for Skywalker there.
Like, so the MKUltra hearings, I think, were canceled or postponed.
And it's kind of interesting, you know, parallel between MKUltra and UFOs.
You know, there's one thing you can know with 100% certainty in this whole mess, is that people
are lying to you, right?
That your government is lying to you.
And, you know, as the United States of America, that's not something we should take lightly.
You know, which brings me back to, you know, the community should be pushing for a select
committee and nothing else.
Because you get subpoena power and you have some real teeth.
And the only way to make sure someone's not lying to you is to have them under oath in
that type of setting.
That's why Sean, you know, Kirkpatrick, Sean Kirkpatsey, you know, he laughs at the whole
process.
Because he's, you know, the same as Lou Elizondo.
It's his job to lie.
Like, they're doing a counterintelligence job.
And I think, you know, no one in the community, I think, asked the question.
I don't even know if anyone asked the question.
This poor Matt Robinson, or whatever the hell his name was, who was, you know, going to testify
in a few months, you know.
Hi, Tom.
What if he was whacked by the people, you know, that he was, you know, what if the whole
thing is trolling for people to, you know, they're looking to bust any leak they can.
And I think another thing you have to consider is, from my research, the UFO program has nothing
to do with demons or aliens, just a bunch of evil fucking, you know, people, unfortunately,
maybe Americans, maybe Nazis, maybe whatever label you want to put them.
And they have the technology, and God knows what kind of shit they're going to pull.
And wouldn't, you know, a bunch of patsy pastors, you know, waiting for the end of times,
you know, wouldn't they be the perfect ones to kind of work it with, you know, to the point
of everyone's comments on connections to the intelligence community and MKUltra?
And it's all about, you know, patsies to use, right?
Yeah, I mean, they may be...
I finally remember Baptists.
Sorry, if I could just continue my point was that you're 100% correct, but the reason
I was pushing back after church every time was because I was obviously not believing everything
in the Bible.
Till to this day, I don't, right?
And it's okay to have a questioning attitude, and the priest was very adamant to say, there's
a lot of things that I don't believe in it either, you know?
Like, this is, to be honest, I've never had a priest sit down.
And be frank with me like this, but he's like, I don't even think that we have the right
version, you know?
So there is some form of control, and it's blasphemous, yeah, to even bring up around another
priest.
That's why I would never divulge his name.
But it's like, there is a way that the government's like, look, there's these commandments.
It's a good social order.
Let's follow in line with this.
It seems to be the most resembling this topic of interdimensionality.
So maybe there is a there there, but pushing back is the most important thing from the belief
system, being able to have that open door conversation.
As the way the priest explains to all of us is the door is always going to be open.
So you can walk in and ask those questions at any time, verbally or internally, you know?
That's what we're here for.
Okay, yeah, no, that's good you have that relationship.
If we could go to Kimball, because he's been waiting to talk with his hand up.
I think he's the next one up.
Go ahead, Kimball.
Yeah, there's a lot of things I wanted to talk about, but we've kind of moved on a little
bit.
I wanted to ask you, though, earlier in the space, probably a couple hours ago, why is it
that you think when it comes to ufology and the government or whatever involvement, why
do you think it's the Catholic Church, the Mormon Church, and Scientology?
No, not the Catholic Church, the Rosicrucians.
And that isn't me saying that.
What I'm saying is people bring those up as groups they are suspicious of.
Now, we hear that from, right, famously from Red Panda Koala.
And Pasulka.
Pasulka, too.
Pasulka, right?
Red Panda Koala and Tupa, right?
But we also, there was a, I believe it was the 25th of April, 2025.
I'm not certain about that date.
It was April, 2025.
Red Panda interviewed Injali.
And the point of that interview, that conversation, was that she was saying that she had been
contacted by former friends or friends who were in the intelligence community.
And I guess they're still active in the intelligence community, who had told her that there were
plans in place in the intelligence community to target individuals who were part of accelerationist
organizations and also individuals involved in Scientology, Mormonism.
I don't know if she said Rosicrucianism or if that was added later by like Red Panda Koala
or Diana Pasulka, but he definitely, or she definitely talked about Mormonism and Scientology.
And the rationale for that was that there was a belief in aliens.
So the story that she told was that there was a policy change.
Now, there's been a change in administration, right?
She was talking in 2000, early 2025, but those conversations probably would have happened closer
to 2024.
There's been a change in administration, so there may be a change in policy.
And, you know, I'm just going on the assumption, she was being honest, that there was a policy
change that was going to target people who believed in a literal UFO presence, right?
And specifically those groups believe in the literal existence of UFOs, right?
So it's not just Rosicrucians, but, you know, Mormons and Scientologists, but also other
esoteric Christian groups would fall into that as well.
So Swedenborgians, right?
But it would be the belief in the actual presence of extraterrestrials.
Go ahead.
Where does the Catholic Church come in?
So the Catholic Church, the purpose of talking about the Catholic Church was that there's
been a recent arrival in the UFOX space of a number of individuals who represent a strong
Catholic perspective.
And at the same time, there have been a number of people like David Grosh who've come forward
and made statements about their Catholic faith.
And so this was a thought experiment.
The thought experiment was, obviously, we know there's no, like, plan behind it, but it's
an unusual thing to happen.
And if we did a thought experiment and said, like, what might be the plan?
Like, if the Vatican had determined or decided to get more involved in the ufology community
and the paranormal community, why might that be the case?
That's where they come in.
But they are involved, and they have been participating with the Department of Defense for a long time.
As long as I can remember, dude.
20-plus years?
Maybe even fucking longer, like, centuries?
I have no idea how far these have been communicated in the background for blessings for war and
for permission to attack things.
You know, they always have been relying on the Vatican's opinion before they do anything
major in the world.
And it seems like now is the time that they're pushing back the most.
Yeah, I mean, I, to me, I'm not, I've never been any, anything, particularly anything associated
with the intelligence community.
So I don't have any knowledge of that.
I assume that you're, you're correct to an extent, but there is a conspicuous, there has
been until very recently, always been a conspicuous absence of Catholicism and the Catholic
worldview in the ufology and paranormal communities.
It's, it's always been a conspicuous to me because I'm from New England.
I think there's a tradition in our government to have an association with the Christian church.
And since the Catholic church seems to be the largest, you know, denomination that association
is made, I don't think there's some conspiracy, right?
I think there's just, administrations have the desire to have the spiritual, you know, asset.
And, and so they involve them.
I don't think the Vatican is controlling the U S government, you know, that's really good.
No, there's no, no, they try to control each other, right?
There's no statement that the Vatican is controlling the U S government.
The, the issue right now is that there are, there are viewpoints, right?
There are, um, what, what I might term as factions, right?
But that's loosely using the definition of factions.
There are, um, groups of people who have similar worldviews who cluster in the paranormal community,
right?
And up until this point, the, the Christian, the Catholic, specifically the Catholic perspective
hasn't been, uh, as vocal.
The Catholic church has made statements about, uh, aliens and the paranormal.
They're, they're not, um, they're probably the closest thing to what Tony's ideal is of
just not paying attention to it, making it a statement, moving on, not paying attention
to it.
That is changing now, or it seems to be changing now.
And so that was the, the point, as far as the, the influence of the Catholic church on
the American government, uh, I, I don't know.
I can't say that right now there's an adversarial relationship developing.
There has been in the past, but right now specifically there is an adversarial relationship
developing, and that may be a factor in the presence of, um, or the, the stronger presence
of the Catholic perspective in the paranormal community.
However, as I pointed out, another hypothetical from a thought, you know, experiment perspective,
hypothetical, uh, rational, reason or rationale for that, um, could be the Epstein files, right?
Because the Catholic church was the organization that broke the Epstein files, right?
So like the Vatican under the direct, um, uh, under the direct orders of Pope Francis were
the ones who were responsible for hacking and, and releasing those files to the U S government.
So they had them and they had all that information prior to the rest of us.
Just to recap though, on what current scientists that are studying consciousness believe, like
James Lukatsky, who served in the DOD at the highest level and has leaked accidentally
information alluding to the fact that we are much more powerful than we understand.
And so that hearts and minds subject, when they start bringing that up, it's because they're
trying to coalesce an entire body of people.
And the Catholic religion is one of the largest.
So Christians, if you can get them to coalesce behind an idea, which, you know, seems to be
a pretty damn good idea, uh, ascension, uh, creating a better fucking paradise, all of those
viewpoints in the Bible that are positive about changing our environment before our eyes and
all these miraculous things.
Like sometimes I like to believe that that's, that's possible and that everybody can do it.
But I don't, I do honestly believe there's these interdimensional factions that are controlling
large bodies of people from behind the scenes through influence and control.
So I, I, I'm, I'm glad I'm here and I know that I know there's a reason I'm here.
So I'm not too buying into all of the drama, but I'd like to watch it unfold.
So thank you very much again.
Cool.
Uh, Kimball, what do you got?
Um, I, so, I mean, I think part, part of it, especially, and I know you weren't like
conflating the Catholic church and being targeted, I guess, by intelligence agencies.
Um, but the Catholic church is very, the Catholic church, the Mormon church, and I presume the
Scientologists, they're very, um, they have a very like robust hierarchical system, right?
Very, um, I mean, they're basically authoritarian like organizations just in their struct, the way
they're structured.
Um, and I wonder if that has something to do with, uh, their ability to be used, um, by
some of these agencies.
Uh, I do also think, frankly, like a lot of this is just conspiracy theory, mumbo jumbo.
Um, I grew up Mormon.
I served a Mormon mission.
I was one of those missionaries.
And some of the things I hear said are just ridiculous.
Um, I, now I can, for sure, like, uh, Mormons are definitely like targeted for some of these,
um, CIA positions, agencies, right?
For a number of reasons.
But I've been interviewed, right?
Like, uh, a federal officer called me up and was like, I need to do a background check on
one of your childhood friends, right?
So he took me out to lunch and like, kind of grilled me on this guy.
And that definitely is a thing, um, right?
The knowing different languages.
I know like CIA agencies have, they went down and sat in the MTC, the missionary training center,
and like studied how Mormons were able to teach these young kids, uh, languages so quickly,
right?
And I will, I will say like, if I were to speculate, maybe I can see possibly like government
agents, um, putting on the tags and pretending to be Mormon missionaries, maybe to get access
or into certain places.
Um, but the idea that like some of these Mormon missionaries are being used by the government
to infiltrate things.
I mean, I can't say for sure it's never happened.
Maybe it has.
I just, I, it seems laughable.
Um, and then the last thing, like if you were to go to a Mormon and, and say, uh, you guys
believe in aliens, um, that's part of your theology.
I think they would probably be offended.
Like, I mean, there, there is some nuance there and that they believe in a, a God with
a physical body, right?
Who lives on a planet, which is a lot more literal than, uh, what mainstream Christians,
I guess, believe.
But, um, yeah, I, I see people kind of making connections where there aren't really any.
Yeah.
I mean, I don't know.
That's the story that, um, she told, uh, I, I have no idea if it's a real story.
I have no idea if it's, um, accurate.
Um, as far as the, the aliens go, um, right.
I would think, I would think that probably everyone would, would be similar in, in Mormon theology,
but I don't know.
Um, but they do believe in life on other planets, right?
Like, so it's, to the best of my knowledge, that's the case.
Um, yeah.
And I will say, like, I learn more, like every, not every day, but like more and more, I'm,
I'm learning how many Mormons really are in, in the UFO topic.
Like paranormal DM me yesterday.
Apparently Kenneth Arnold himself was like a Mormon.
Like there's so many Mormons in this topic.
Yeah.
The connection to the government as well, Mormonism and all the other religions, they, they really
study them in the intelligence community just to see what gains certain value.
And that, that's why they, uh, I don't know, they, they push on certain aspects and how
they, they try to tell the Catholic church, you should consider that, you know, telepathy
and remote viewing and the information that these people are getting from the higher realms.
And to consider the fact that there possibly is way too many rules that you guys are following.
And I'm not, I'm not trying to pick on the Catholic faith.
Remember when I do, when I do push back, it's against my own faith, right?
Cause I'm a Catholic, but I'm thinking that because of everything that's been coming out
with the studies of, you know, the psychedelic side of the entire thing coupled with religiosity
is that the whole commandment structure might be not as, uh, strict as you think it is,
is that what they're trying to tell us from the other side is that everybody goes wherever
they want after this.
And it is, it brings up the whole game simulation theory is that you decide from here where you
want to go and, and life is ever.
That's basically what Mormons believe right there.
Yeah.
And that, that, that a little bit of every faith has a, has some play in the truth.
And that's why I think that I know it's cliche that one world government, one religion,
but I think if we, if we, you can yourself on your journey, find all the great aspects of
every practice and put them into play, I think that's what you're going to find is, is unlock
that, you know, super God code on your own.
I think the, the side stuff for sure, uh, I guess overlays or interlocks with, um, Mormon
theology a lot more than anything else in the paranormal.
I mean, you see Paul H Smith, right?
He's like one of the leading, um, remote viewing teachers these days, and he's very active in
the Mormon church.
So I, I definitely can see some of that.
Yeah, I don't want to sound like a crystal bitch and all that and love and light, but
there is a lot of truth to, to all of that, you know, the dimensionality and the frequency
of where you end up is how you carry your life is where you go.
It doesn't matter if you broke some commandments, it's how you're resonating at the time of the
completion of your journey and what you learned.
It's not all because of what one thing you did that you get cast into the shadows, right?
That's where I think is what the disclosure is really about.
Oh, uh, the one thing I mentioned, red pandas at it in a space a couple of days ago, restitution
is, is tied into the Catholic church.
That is a lie.
We're at conflict with that.
The same as like Freemasons were not allowed.
Oh yeah.
I've had priests knife hand me out of their space for talking like this guys.
You understand how serious it is that people are so brainwashed into this, uh, faith and
it's my own faith.
And I love that.
You know, I still love a lot of aspects of it.
I love getting together and feeling the energy of everyone in the room.
And I could see my son who is on the spectrum can see all these different colors in front
of him.
And the priests are like, he could see.
And I'm like, yes, he can.
And it's like, it's an amazing experience.
I know it sounds woo, but there's other things that he could see that we can't.
And so that makes me believe that there's a there there.
Thanks.
And I think, I think I miss perception that people have about the Catholic churches.
It's not that we don't believe in astral projection.
It's not that we don't believe in mediums.
It's not that we don't believe in all these things, right?
It's actually quite the opposite.
We do.
And we're warned.
Don't mess with that stuff because it opens portals and you can end up getting yourself
in trouble.
So it's not that we don't believe.
It's just, you know, the occult, the new age stuff, they acknowledge that this stuff actually
works.
This stuff is actually real, but we're told do not play with it because you're opening yourself
up to the unknown that you might lose.
Because what?
You might learn how to heal yourself.
You might learn how to extend your life.
You might learn how to act in harmony with the environment.
Skywalker, you got to let people finish, man.
I'm sorry, man.
I'm sorry.
I'm just getting a little, I'm getting a little self-righteous for that.
Sorry, bud.
Go ahead.
No, that could be dangerous.
That's all.
True.
If you don't know what you're doing and they just tell you not to do it.
Like, like new age is paganism.
It's not new.
It's, it was there in the beginning.
It's not a new religion.
It's not a new thing.
It's always been there.
And if you talk to theologians in the Catholic church or exorcists, they'll tell you all this
stuff is real.
It, it works.
You can do it, but you open yourself up if you don't know how to protect yourself.
You don't have a good safety net.
Absolutely.
It is a, it is a different kind of world now.
People are learning, you know, basic shamanism practices just to kind of balance the energy
in their household, even though you might want to consider it witchcraft or, but, you know, in, in the same church that you go to, they're burning incense with the same, you know, material that you're using from, from your own home.
So there's no reason why you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you in effect change them just because of the vibration that your own home carries, you know?
Yeah.
No, I hear what you're saying.
Um, we're, we're drawing towards close to the end of the space.
Um, I want to hear what artisan Tony has to say.
And then Michael, who just, um, who just came up.
I was just going to, I was just going to say that I was sitting here listening to all these individual personal beliefs.
And it occurred to me that, you know, no, there's no Catholic, all Catholics don't believe the same thing.
All Southern Baptists don't believe the same thing.
All Mormons don't believe exactly the same thing.
But what is happening now is that we're all being sort of herded together under this one belief of UFOs.
And I think I find that interesting, uh, but I don't know.
I find, I don't know why I just thought that was interesting.
Anyway, thanks.
Yeah.
That's one of the accusations, right?
It's one of the possible, uh, when people start talking about plot, plot, yeah, project blue beam, right?
That's what it's talking about is, uh, UFOs or fake UFOs being used to bring people together.
Real UFOs, real aliens could also be used as a way of bringing people together.
Humanity, people always tend to unite against common enemies, right?
Um, that would be nice to say, like, you could have, uh, you could have like peaceful, loving extraterrestrials land and everyone would unite together, but that's less represented in human nature than the propensity to unite against a common enemy.
So that's the whole concept of blue beam is allegedly to create a common enemy that would bring everyone together into sort of one big, um, artificial belief system, artificial nation.
I don't, I'm not, I'm not necessarily a proponent of blue beam though, to be honest with you.
I, at the fact when, when they bring things up in, in Star Trek episodes years prior to anyone else, you know, talking about it anywhere else, you know, that makes me suspicious.
Uh, Michael, go ahead.
Uh, uh, Kimbo, I, I just wanted to let Michael talk, um, cause he hasn't said anything.
Go ahead, Michael.
Sorry.
I, I just wanted to put on something about the, when you start talking into the unknown and to beings and into the ether, you don't know what's talking back to you exactly.
So I, I have some skepticism and be careful about what you're doing because you never know.
Sorry.
I don't know much.
Oh, I think that's, it's a very valid point.
I think that's the thing that Matt was talking about too.
And that's a concern that people have, right.
And have had for thousands of years that even if 90% of the time or 99% of the time, it's, it's innocuous or it's beneficial or it's neutral.
Um, if you know, a certain percentage of the time you're going to, you're going to bring back a, a hitchhiker, some sort of, uh, negative entity, right.
That's, that's definitely should weigh very seriously in the considerations that you use.
Or it could be your own mind, right?
Well, sure.
I mean, if you're going to have a psychotic break, the same thing would be true.
Go ahead, Gamble.
Yeah, I think that's definitely true.
Um, people wonder and they're curious and that's good.
But, um, there is, you know, this topic can get dark at a point, right?
And sort of the phrase, uh, once you open that door, you can't always close it.
So that's definitely something people should be mindful of.
Um, a question you asked me earlier, JT, or some points you made.
I, I want to, I think it's important and I'm glad you brought it up, right?
And, um, it's, it's difficult for me emotionally to talk about.
And it also doesn't really land because people know there's beef.
But, um, just the idea, like, uh, there is sort of a cocooning, the way you said it, with Red and Tupa, where, like, new people who come in the community or, like, prominent people who are coming in and talking about it for the first time.
They often kind of, there's sort of this, uh, almost like a briefing, right?
They get a little, it's funny, they talk about the UFO hate group, uh, back in the day when this first started, uh, you know, so Juan got the talk, right?
It was, like, the talk.
But, uh, you'll see a lot of people who come in, even, even just regular people who start talking in spaces will get the talk, right?
They'll get the, the whole, like, download sort of thing of, like, okay, this is how it is.
They have a really, uh, strong need to sort of, uh, control and, uh, remain prominent in, in the, uh, community here.
And I think a lot of that is born out of, um, the fact that they were harassed and targeted, um, you know, and, and we could debate back and forth whether, you know, some of that was justified or not.
But that definitely is a thing, uh, that, that they do, and it, it's, uh, caused me, uh, pain and, uh, frustration.
But I just, I, I can't believe how many people just, uh, gobble everything up that they say and don't question any of it.
They like the drama, huh, Kimball?
Is, uh, they rehash it out, like, at least quarterly now.
They're doing it less and less, but it is, uh, one of those sore subjects for them that remains, uh, you know,
there's a tiny bit of evidence behind it.
And I give them a little bit of, you know, that's, that's the, that's the day I'm not going to be in spaces because I know what they're talking about.
And, um, I fully support those guys.
That's their niche.
People eat that shit up and it, and it gets a lot of views.
And, uh, people don't want to understand a little bit more about Lou Elizondo's other side, you know, like there is another side.
He actively is talking to these podcasters behind it.
Like, hey man, I need, I need you to not ask me this, that, and the other, or pre-gaming questions.
But Skywalker, you don't know that, right?
You're being, you've been told that repeatedly by Tupor and Red and you believe it.
You're selectively giving information out.
I don't know, man.
It doesn't seem...
Well, so are they.
That's the point.
Like, you don't know if any of that's true.
I had Lou on my show twice and he didn't, he never, I sent him a show prep and he didn't make any comments about it.
So there was no manipulation or, you know.
It's all, yeah, it's all conspiracy and paranoia, right?
I'll agree the bombastic nature of the fighting and I don't like it, but, um, some of the evidence he has, sorry, I got a call.
Um, some of the evidence stands out a little bit.
Like, I need to, I need to review this a little more because there's some threats.
There's some serious, uh, in the, these guys take care of themselves, clips, you know, like almost alluding to that they would, uh, they probably aren't going to.
Very much longer.
Man, someone's really blasting my phone right now while I'm trying to talk.
Look, here's the thing.
I don't, I'm not trying to litigate their issues with somebody else.
I'm not, I'm not a Lou Elizondo guy.
I'm not on any crew.
I'm not, you know, the, the reason that this is important to me specifically is that, you know, this is a, a space specifically about UFO X, right?
It's not a space about the archons.
It's not a space about remote viewing.
It's a space about UFO X and some changes that I've noticed, or I believe I've noticed, right?
It could be in my mind.
Um, you're right.
I'd like to take it in that direction because I'll keep defending Tupo and red the entire time.
And that's going to get, we know you will.
We know you will.
That's the thing, right?
So that's why I'm asking everyone's perspective, right?
Like I, if this was a different subject, then maybe, maybe I wouldn't, but I, it's not my place to tell you, I, or, or Kimball or our artisan or, or Tom or anyone else what to say about UFO X, right?
Because I'm not the UFO X guy.
True.
Okay.
We keep it fun though.
We keep, we keep it light.
Of course.
Yeah.
So that's right.
And that's why I, I preface things by saying, look, let's try to do this.
If you can like try to answer this without emotion, right?
Try to give an objective perspective because I understand there are so many, um, there's so much water under the bridge.
Right.
But you, for me, what, what stands out is that, you know, it happened again.
It happened again with that pastor and immediately, like as soon as he was done talking, the, the, the tweet started using what he said to,
either debunking what he said or using what he said to hammer home a different point.
And it's a desire to control the narrative.
Right.
And, and what I wonder is where, where does the desire come from?
Is it, you know, is it just personal interest or is it something else?
And right.
Based on that, what effect does that have on the, the question in hand?
Right.
So right now we have two new regular spaces.
We have Mav space, seven o'clock at night, most nights, right?
We have Jean space on the, uh, on the weekend.
Right.
And, um, on, uh, uh, Sunday syndicate.
So that's going to change the, the discussion.
And what I have to say about this is like Mav does a good job.
Right.
And, um, Jean also does a good job.
And they're both very intelligent individuals.
I do like how both sides are intermingling and everyone's cross, uh, kind of like pollinating
with, um, the emojis that you guys Mav have.
Skywalker, let him finish.
Here's the thing.
Okay.
What is the future, right?
If we have this now, this, the Catholic perspective is here and we have a, uh, a different way
of looking at things, right?
We have people quoting the official position of the, of the Vatican on, on UFOs.
We have a new way of approaching these, these questions.
It doesn't have all that drama behind it.
That's based on bringing in guests from different areas of the paranormal and asking them intellectual
questions or intelligent questions.
And, you know, what does that mean?
Right.
And I think that if I was two for a red, I would take that very seriously because they're
very good at what they do, but it's a one trick at this point.
Okay.
It is, it is one trick at this point.
And I don't think they can compete.
I'm not saying that they want to, but I think that they're going to do the same things to
try to compete and maintain their, their share.
And I don't think they can compete with the people who are coming in who are going to be
approaching things from, from a different perspective, right?
If they're going to try the same marketing strategy, we'll just call it a marketing strategy.
Right.
So marketing, she's not selling anything.
He's just trying to have fun while he's learning about the subject.
You don't think he's making money doing this.
I'm sure he is.
I'm just proud of him.
I'd be proud of him and be like, that's good for you, dude.
You know?
Yeah.
I mean, look, he's very good at, they're both very good at being influencers better than
I will ever be at being an influencer.
Right.
So they don't influence me though.
Okay.
Well, they influence someone and they're very creative.
They're better than I am at it.
So I'm not, their capabilities.
And I'm, you know, I'm just saying it relates to this topic specifically because whether they
intend to or not, they do function as a gatekeeper for a certain number of people to this topic.
And therefore, if you're going to have any discussion, you have to factor in, well, what
are Red and Tupa going to do?
How are they going to approach it?
Because they are capable of slowing the dissemination of knowledge.
That kind of sounds like something that like, uh, like David Wilcox attackers were, it would
say is like, let me start, we got to start forming a coalition.
That's weird.
That sounds weird.
The word coalition was never part of what I said.
What I said was they are going to, they are gatekeepers and they are going to have a power
over how things disseminate that I never said anything about a coalition, about Tupacabra
and right there.
I'm not in UFO.
Hold on, please.
Cause he just accused me of something.
I'm not part of UFO X.
I don't have a coalition.
I don't have any people in UFO X.
I don't have a faction.
I don't have any of that.
So it really is beyond me.
I'm talking about this from an outsider's perspective and I don't have any part in the
drama.
No, I never have any part in the drama.
I don't give a fuck.
Right.
So you can project that, but it's interesting.
What is interesting is that that's how you interpret things, right?
Not just you, because it's how other people interpret things too.
Don't let me in.
I'll make you this promise, JT.
I'll never, I'll play both sides.
I'll tell you where they went wrong and I'll tell you where you guys went wrong.
There is no attempt to form a coalition against anyone or to influence things at all.
The important thing is the conversations that we're having, right?
And there is a gate, there is a bottleneck.
There are gatekeepers.
And so they themselves and their position and their behavior is important, regardless
of whether you love them or don't.
That's why I follow them.
So I can help correct them if they go off the deep end.
I'm like, hey man, maybe you're thinking about this wrong.
Can you try to consider this?
We're going to let Kendall, Kendall, Kimball, sorry, dude.
Kimball talk.
Sounds like you're gatekeeping.
Yeah, I'm gatekeeping.
One side.
We're going to let Kimball talk and then I'm going to have to wrap it up because I
I can't pronounce a name anymore.
I'm just getting tired.
I can only talk for a couple hours.
It's me.
It's my mental acuity is slipping.
Go ahead, Kimball.
Yeah.
So there's a prominent member of not this community so much, but of ufology that I was
chatting with at a conference.
And he mentioned how Red Panda Koala did a lot of good work.
And I actually am advocating Red's YouTube channel pretty often.
I feel like if you're just getting into the topic, his videos really are very educational.
But he said the issue with Red Panda Koala is that he weaponizes his information.
And I definitely think that's true.
I agree.
I do think they intend to gatekeep.
They definitely do.
And that's kind of the problem.
The point should be we should come into spaces like this.
And Mav does an excellent job with this as well.
So does Gene.
And be able to exchange ideas and disagree and leave it there.
The issue, especially with Red, I think, is if you disagree with his little conspiracy narrative
and the UFO hate group or whatever, you're immediately treated differently, right?
And they'll make memes.
And people like Skywalker will say it's all in good fun.
But, you know, you'll get treated a certain way, right?
If you happen to have a different idea or a different theory or you disagree with some of their theories.
And so it's led to an ecosystem here in UFO X that I don't think is productive because it's like you got to go with one narrative.
And it's funny because you hear them and, again, especially Red talk about, you know, the deep state and Scientology and gang stalking and harassment.
And almost all of that is projection.
I mean, that's kind of the way he operates is some of those same, through those same things.
So I just would warn people, not as I could dig at them specifically, but we're all aware, right, on this topic of narrative control, right?
And psyops.
And we all assume it's from some government agency.
But just be careful.
It could come from people here in the community.
May I respond, Mr. Kimball?
All right.
So I think that they weaponize information to protect themselves in a way.
And I'll use an example.
When their information gets doxxed and put all over the web and his sister gets her picture put on X by some other fucking weirdo creeps.
You're right.
That's very, that's like weaponizing information to me, right?
That scares me.
That makes me support them.
I need to end the space.
Yeah, you can end the space because I know it's not going your way.
And you guys are fucking idiots.
Whatever.
I criticized his doxxing louder than anyone, dude.
No one should be getting doxxed.
All right, dude.
I don't know what's not going my way.
I'm sorry that you...
Because you guys can't really...
You guys are seriously one-sided against Tupa still?
See how defensive Skywalker is?
It's a cult.
You can't build a bridge.
To a degree, it is a cult.
Let's be honest.
Anyway...
I'm more interested in why you said it was more of a psychotic episode than anything.
I didn't say anything was a psychotic episode.
I said...
I think we were talking about...
Jesus, I don't even know what we were talking about.
I'm getting tired.
Like someone else said mental health or something.
And I was like, yeah, like a psychotic episode.
So I was just adding to what somebody else was saying.
I wasn't making an argument that anything was more than a psychotic episode.
You can talk about inner space and reading people's minds and everything.
And then you just randomly throw a psychotic episode out there.
Who's talking?
I can't even see who's talking.
It's Michael.
Michael.
No, Michael.
I didn't randomly throw anything out of anywhere.
It was part of the conversation.
I'm sorry that you feel that way.
So, yeah.
I'm wrapping up the space.
Everyone was maintaining very well until the end.
And then we started to get some trollish behavior, right?
And that's fine.
But if that was where it was always going to go, it could have led with that.
And then, you know, we could have moved on.
There was never any argument for things not to go our way.
Because we weren't having an argument, right?
And nor was this a space about red and two.
But this is a space about the fact a new perspective has emerged, okay?
And how that's going to go.
Because it's not just happening here in UFOX.
It's happening in ufology in general.
And it's that behavior specifically, which is why I don't think anyone is going to be able
to compete very well, right?
Because people don't want that, right?
People don't want to go through a two-hour space and at the end of the space, you know,
have the people like, surprise, we're trolls, okay?
I mean, it's...
And this whole...
And to identify that that's what they were all about the whole time.
Like the whole time, you know, they had this subtle master plan where they were winning
this argument that other people didn't even know existed.
So, it's just ridiculous.
I wish Tupor the best.
I wish him well.
I wish Red Panda the best.
I wish them well.
I mean, we're not part of the same anything.
But if it makes those guys feel better to say that they won, and Tupor and Red won, then
they did.
They won.
It's congratulations to them.
I don't...
Again, I'm not...
I didn't know I was in any competition with them.
So, I am going to end the space.
I do look forward to Mav's space in the near future with Pastor DiDilio.
I look forward to Sunday Night Syndicate with Gene Sticko.
Like I said, it's getting tough for me to pronounce.
JT, can I quickly...
Yeah, go ahead and plug what you want.
I'm doing...
On Fridays, I'm going to start doing a UFO weekly recap as far as, like, all the news.
So, I put that up in the nest.
It'll be tomorrow at 6 Central.
Okay.
Yeah, tomorrow at 6 Central.
Yep.
Thanks, man.
Great space.
And thank you guys for all coming in and having, you know, this conversation.
And I look forward to following all these spaces.
And you're all welcome back in my next space, including those other guys.
But if I know that's what they're up to, I'm just going to give them one question and
then, you know, show them the door after that, right?
So, that's not my place to rule anyone out because it's not my community, right?
So, that would be very boring for me and I'm not going to do that.
All right, guys.
Have a good night.
There's been like a 10-second silence at the end.
And I hope to see you all soon.
Bye.